[Music]
4 3 2 hello everybody it is Friday we
are here hello Ela hello hello
everybody a very half-hearted CL uh
Applause
[Music]
today a Let There we go that's what I'm
talking about that's now I'm feeling
energized
um thank you for being here it is
October 20th
[Music]
Halloween mhm it's C somewh else yeah
you can feel it in the air yeah
parents it's the biggest day of the year
God I remember being a kid and Halloween
is just such a special day and you know
it's nice to be able to live vicariously
MH through the kids cuz I I can buy
candy now right I can buy I can buy
candy anytime I want you know what I
mean I can buy it right
now with your job you can also wear a
costume whenever you want too true I
there's no rules baby I'm Halloween
every
day that's awesome that's a life hack yo
uh Sam insta card some family or some uh
bite-size Snickers please say less I
will do it right now and a bob wig I'm
kidding I don't need those wait really
no so you don't want me to no I don't
thank you breaking hearts I just I I I
know I know I know I'm sorry I'm
sorry um so what else is going we have a
great show planned today really fun
stuff on the
horizon um we have two great segments
planned today one of them is a
continuation of the artistic expression
of us on the crew here at the a stre
podcast you know I am amuse of sorts I
accept that and especially to all these
guys who come into work every day they
look up to me they
idolize and I mean how would you how
would you describe your feelings for me
AB oh man it was tough it was tough
there was so much to say and we only
could you know write 14 lines so 14
lines which is the traditional length of
a sonnet right although I I would be
impressed if anyone actually took on the
task of writing a Shakespearean sonnet
that would be cool but no pressure also
no pressure I didn't work with scansion
sadly I didn't Implement that so each
crew member U wrote me a 14 line or less
poem 14 pages that's right
14 lines lines we should say uh Zach
isn't here today cuz otherwise that
already would have been played yeah
already so we're going to have to fill
in just verbally with all the soundes oh
no he's not here today damn but is in
our head always I got to not let him go
off I need need to not take days
off it's not cool uh so I'm going to
read them off and then guess whose poem
is who and clearly you're so good at it
my track record is not
good but I am poetry is my uh college
major right it should be your area of
expertise I met Ethan he was writing
poems
W dude what for listen the reason I
chose
poetry is because yeah and I was proven
right it's a subset of the literature
major and it's the easiest [__] major
at the whole damn School hell yeah yes
and I'll happy to tell to report to all
you guys out there maybe some of you
guys at the the later stag of your high
school experience if you're listening or
but if you go to
UCC do creative writing you will not
ever do any work at all ever don't teach
them that didn't you almost fail out too
I failed out yeah I did fail out and
then I had to go to I had to go to
Community College for a year and then I
I did finish right right yeah right and
then you became a millionaire there you
go what does that tell you D thank you
Cameron anything appreciate
that but um yeah the The Poetry major
there was so
[__] I mean listen how do you teach
poetry it's like you know what I mean
like you can work like me going to Art
School how do you teach art it's kind of
like I mean my my poetry teacher who is
an accomplished poet and a really great
terrific guy yeah but at the same time
it's like you can't read someone's poem
and be like you didn't do this right
right unless it's like very specific
very subjective but for the most part
all we did was just
like have a topic write something and
then just workshop and then for our our
final you know thesis dissertation
whatever we just literally just made a
book of all the poems we read I bound it
with tape I have it and I still
B+ it
looks it looks
like like Ethan is describing it's paper
and tape nice it's and because well we
were supposed to do this whole did
others do like a book yeah yeah that we
were supposed to do like a really we so
different as
students I took everything so seriously
my objective at that in that um I was
valedictorian what I remember I went to
your what celebration whoa a minute
honored yes yeah she was honored I was
there I think that's new elore I don't
think that's ever been revealed she's
[Music]
a that your oh [__] wait okay
I'm just doing you a favor thanks yeah
so you were saying that um so you're
going at a later age to college you go
you because you do the Army you go at a
later age yes which actually is a really
good point you're more mature like when
I went to school I was like 17 or 18 or
something and like you are such an
irresponsible dumb little [__] piece
of [__] then like if I went my mid-20s I
would definitely have learned a lot more
mhm that's what I did I
I delayed going to college yeah I didn't
go to college then I mean that wasn't
necessarily you went to Community
College is that I wouldn't characterize
it that way uh I did a couple Community
College classes but for the most part I
just I I started working right after
high school and then I decided to go
back to college around I think I was 23
so like you're saying like mid 20s is
one interesting yeah there were people
that did that in our like in the dorms
and we thought they were such weirdos
though cuz they look so old not like 24
but some of them were like pushing 30 in
the dorms and we're like yeah I didn't
live in a dorm I had my own place but
they're not they're just trying to live
their life so weird that you don't want
to pay like $100,000 to just go get
drunk and right right I'm not going to
lie though having a degree in English
literature did help me a lot when I
moved to Israel getting a professional
job yeah like a lot he had like job
opportunities just because of that right
which was weird cuz in I was like I'm
never going to [__] get J I'm going
to work I'm going to be a waiter I was
waiting and you know listen for a lot of
people that's as that's a great job for
for for people
that so many of us that's that's like
kind of the best paying job that you're
going to find
mhm and
so cuz there was jobs that came up in
Santa Cruz you remember that one they
were looking for like a junior level
marketer that I was like was like okay
and it was paying like $3 or $40,000 a
year I was like this is going to change
our life I get this m that is so insane
so much insane money and
um I was like gushing over this resume
and cover letter and I was just like
agonizing over it sent it to him waited
a week I hadn't heard anything and then
I called him just to check in you know
like a good applicant and they go man we
got so many app for that we probably
didn't even read yours like it's sorry
it's just unless you have like a lot of
experience we didn't even look at your
cuz there and and the ad the posting was
for entry level Junior but have lots of
experience so sad living in San Cruz
that was the hardest part actually cuz I
in Israel it's like if you want to get a
job you can literally go to a restaurant
and start working the next day pretty
much that's what I was used to and so
when I got there I was like assuming
I'll be able to work no problem and then
I couldn't find any jobs like nothing
you just walk into like an ice cream
shop and they have a pile that's
literally what happened have a pile of
applications they don't they're like
there's no point for you to even fill an
application either went to a yoger store
and she's like hey are you guys hiring
he's like you can fill an application
but I have a stack of them like this
stick and I it took forever to I at the
end I did find something but it was like
forever it was a miracle you found like
a a good like uh that was a nanny a
nanny gig yeah but like I think that was
a Santa Cruz thing cuz the there's it's
a relatively small town with a ton of
college students right so it's just like
too many young people looking for entry
level jobs yeah it's just the worst
place to be Santa Cruz is Tiny it's like
weird that there's a big college there
mean [__] half the population is
probably college kids right yeah so I I
think in most it's not always as bad as
that but it was pretty it was pretty sad
pretty desperate times there but what
why am I talking what am I talking I
don't know we were you were setting up
the Poetry thing so anyway uh the crew
will has written me poems and uh it's
going to be really a beautiful touching
experience for all of us and I will
guess with stunning
accuracy um who wrote which one also
another segment we have planned uh which
is going to be a ton of fun there's been
a great debate happening not just here
but around the world de I would love to
chime in on that one the dishwasher yeah
there are two camps of thinking H do you
pre-wash the dishes or do you not
pre-wash the dishes now from our early
uh you know uh polling yeah the vast
majority of people are saying You must
pre-wash mhm that's me but we've
conducted
experiments and also experiment singular
I guess we should should say well was
there one more than one dishwashed there
true right okay then
you um and we also have an expert
calling in Tom Wards who was a appliance
uh professional also well versed
in dishwashing machines is what call oh
yeah I hear he also does interviews
sometimes he's I don't first and
foremost dishwash sales better at if
it's pre-wash dishwash or
whatever let's do a we'll do a poll when
we start that segment cuz I'm curious
where the people are and then after we
finish where they are you know MH mhm so
wow so much fun things to uh do today my
goodness uh today's episode is sponsored
by
nobody W thank you that's not quite true
though it is sponsored by viewers like
you our wonderful members who support us
who Lift us up who say we value what you
do and we want you to continue doing it
we see you and we love you and we
appreciate you thank so much to our
members and of course I appreciate all
of our Watchers you are all my my
children I love you all they're your
children they're my children I love you
all the same but I like the people that
pay a little more than
you it's a little
smell I didn't I did not clog the
toilet I don't smell anything maybe have
a a seizure your upper
lip
um Chrissy says in Li of it being spooky
season have y'all watched The Reckless B
video on mainy Manor I
haven't I
haven't uh but I am aware of the mainy
manor thing I I've watched videos about
him I've seen the videos he makes that
dude is sick his Scientology series is
really good oh yeah that's how I found
out about my Discord will not start
uh take look so um also I'll just give a
shout out to Teddy fresh Classics head
on over
there Zach yeah thanks for
that check out
this pocket tea guess how much this
pocket tea cost 22 freaking dollars of
beautiful perfect weight engineered it
is going to fit and feel amazing we have
beautiful colors in the face of uh
inflation and stagnant salaries we said
our prices we're going to make a
collection where the prices don't go up
they go down wow and so we eat into our
margin and we have cost effectively as
possible
brought to you very special collection
the classics uh everything here is
basically as good priced as humanly
possible and the quality is fantastic
it's a perfect thing for you and your
loved ones thank you to
Classics thank you to Teddy fresh.com
yeah yeah
yeah um this is an important
announcement what you got I want to tell
you please actually here let me do it
with him cuz it's fun today is
the cut off day please after the 20th of
October no more fan mail so true wow so
true it's important that we acknowledge
um Ringo membrance day he's still alive
need this day peace and love day it's
his birthday when is his birthday uh
Ringo the peace and love day is his
birthday every year yeah cuz there's in
a right July 7th is uh I believe peace
and love day he do a video every year
where he goes birthday I want everybody
at 12:00 at the same time all around the
world to go outside and say peace and
got it I have seen that right such a guy
such a great guy Legend dude's like 80
and he looks like healthier than me it's
all that peace and love I guess all
right and money well talking about how
you look you actually slay
today and thank you
Ela I mean people always want me to do a
fit check but maybe you should do a fit
check I mean it's just the a nice shirt
this is a shirt I bought three years ago
I found I saw it on sale on Essence
which is like
a designer it's like a Banana Republic
Outlet or
something listen it's it's like a
designer uh store but every year they
have like crazy discounts so I always go
there at the end of the year this was
like 75% off got it for like $200 and
it's like 1,000 I said [__] you this is
a off-white shirt
it is gorgeous and I have never worn it
because I've always been since the
moment I got it too fat this is the
first time I have ever worn this shirt
in 3 years wooo let's go dude's
go beautiful shirt wow with the tattoo
as well
yeah High Beast
Alert in the most painful spot too we're
stepping into a new era that tattoo must
have hurt I'm going get a t I'm about to
that tattoo looks painful I'm going to
do a face Tad next
man what should I cat on my
face King of the
Jews oh my God star David on my love
he's in
love anyway so thank you Ela you're
welcome let's let's honor Ringo though
it's not about me it's not about
anything else let's honor today is
October 20th a hollow day here in the HC
podcast
this is a serious message to everybody
watching my upate right now peace and
love peace peace and love I want to tell
you please after the the 20th of October
do not send fan mail to any address that
you have be after the 20th of October if
it's a date on the envelope it's going
to be TOs
warning you with peace and love I have
too much to do more thank you thank you
and no to
sign anyway
PE
wow love
it Well Done special day obviously not
perfect but pretty good yeah but God
that speech is just so
iconic the first time anyone was warned
with peace and love and that changed the
world
I am warning you with peace and love
it's going to be
tossed ah he's so fun I love Ringo
man so we honor him of course ring
Ringo's in chat way yeah we have a Ringo
uh emoji on the channel yes Ringo in
chat people it's October 20th thank you
thank you uh we got all kinds of fun
stuff at the top of the show here what
time is Tom calling in I know he has a
heart out uh 2:15 which is in about uh
20 minutes okay so Tom Ward of course we
are working around his schedule he's a
busy man he's got interviews he got a
lot going on celebrities yeah it's a big
deal so let's see how about some Gatsby
Karen gets
arrested sure doesn't sound too
bad Karen got locked up when the cart is
crazy oh this this is really really
special let me let me go back here for
you guys to enjoy
what kind of America is this yeah put it
on Facebook they're arresting me for
trying to pay for
my what it's at Walmart too makes it all
better that's amazing it's like how did
she even know someone was recording it
looks like a bit know what kind of
America is this let put it on Facebook
they're arresting me for trying to pay
the for
my is she cuffed they cuffed her
wow wait how is she operating I think
the other officer they're pushing it oh
they're pushing it or he's or is he
pushing the
throttle on the gas they're like you're
too dangerous to be holding this you're
a danger to yourself other so wait what
did she do then I wonder she was trying
to get something for her daughter it
sounds like
rning she has a lot of [__] in her over
stuff just running over lgbq to stands
and stuff
sure what kind of America is this yes
put it on Facebook they're arresting me
for this is actually ironically the most
American right possible screen capture
of all time yeah it really is actually I
mean let's let's examine this you have a
Karen in a in a Mobility Scooter mhm
with a at Walmart right she's got tons
of uh clothing in her cart there she's
being escorted out by police who of
course you know aab and I and I want to
remind people when I say aab I am
talking about Paw Patrol right included
you know it's All or
Nothing
um I don't know I mean sheesh what's
more what what could be less American
what more American is this yes put it on
Facebook 35 cents what are they selling
for 35 cents at Walmart what can you buy
for 35 cents a bucket what is this
interesting good question a binder I
think a binder dude crazy good deal
that's why they're the [__] Best In
The Biz America number one
355 cents dude that's insane also this
is like the scooter of the store because
I see another one oh [__] good
observation it's not
hers so she refused to stand up she
didn't bring her own scooter cuz she
walked in she used their
scooter oh this is this is good this is
good one more time uh with peace and
love is this yes put it on Facebook
they're arresting me for trying to pay
for
my put it on Facebook
everybody I was trying to find some info
about the arrest but uh coming up empty
so far there's a lot of arrests at
Walmart it turns out so the the news is
a little
flooded yeah well I mean you know
Walmart house is like a quarter of the
population at any given time right every
I think women have birth in
Walmart I'm sure that's happened that
gives a whole new meaning to spill on
aisle for oh um our our good friend
Jeremy from the quartering gave birth to
a
turd yeah he gave birth to a turd right
on the floor his his water broke mhm all
kinds of spillage
happening and he just let it loose
baby
Unleashed yeah uh yesterday or not not
yesterday
Wednesday we oh here we go actually um
us woman gives birth to baby girl in
Walmart there you go there it is
wrong congratulations G baby girl in
Walmart toilet paper aisle okay
interesting information
perect hopefully it was a really
absorbent
aisle it's just a
random Missouri woman sexually gave
birth to a baby girl while surrounded by
bare shelves and Corona virus fearing
shoppers oh oh thank you for painting
this uh this stage for me is this a
different one AB it is M wow lots of bur
that was probably like the height of Co
when the shelves were empty yeah you'd
be a little bit worried about germs
giving birth on the floor
huh be so paranoid um father gives birth
in checkout line lady you don't need to
pay for
that an unnamed woman in Utah walked
into Walmart to buy a few items and
walked out with a baby oh my God she
gave birth at register 11 why do we need
to know the register
number which has now dubbed register
Baby by store associate she went to the
register uh she was in distress on her
knees holding her stomach the store
manager told her to push no I'm
kidding just just before she went into
full labor she insisted on paying for
her merchandise oh my God but we weren't
really interested in taking her money at
that point but she insisted it wasn't
like she was like okay let's get this
baby and I'll pay they took her money
she
paid there it
is so hey there's another one there's a
ton this this article is titled people
cheer after woman gives birth at
Missouri Walmart this is a [__]
another article of a woman giving birth
that Walmart in Missouri I think now we
need we know what I need to do for the
third baby well you were looking for
good hospitals I mean you're looking for
a bargain look go to Walmart Isle 11
apparently Isis 11 has really good
support system there for
you customers cheered at Walmart in
Missouri after a woman gave birth to a
baby in the store's toilet oh this is
the same one so there was just a mob
cheering her on watching my God
customers encouraged the women
throughout their birth and cheered as
she and the baby were taken away in an
ambulance bro what I I've seen birth
it's pretty it's not for the faint of
heart I can't imagine people lining up
they're cheering that got the [__] out
of there like hey get out yeah get that
[__] out of here it's
co but I guess hey that's a beautiful
human uh Testament to humanity we love
each other there's a scooter Maga car is
this the same lady oh another angle yeah
yeah yeah this is the longer version of
the same video y extended version okay
this is this is actually huge
this is huge so let's see this is
hopefully give us some
Intel refuse to I'm an Infidel I a 3er
have a it's a it's a mask thing oh
that's what it is it's a mask she's a
3center she's she's part of a uh um
armed
militia that's according to her I love
that she said I I refuseed to sit
down
I'm standing up for what's right no
you're not wait hold on I think 3center
might mean something else what does that
mean Dan it's a like a white nationalist
thing or like a 3er militia yeah cuz I'm
reading that that me Infidel what does
that mean 3ers a militia movement which
supports the idea of a small number of
dedicated Patriots protecting the
America from government tyranny hell
yeah okay cuz I thought maybe she was
talking about diabetes and I don't mean
that
like
what no I didn't mean that I like cuz
obviously diabetes is serious condition
what well it says 3% I thought it was
that she was like ill part of the 3% I
can't wear a mask cuz I don't breathe so
good with the diabetes okay
well you're not alone but actually I I
don't think that's what she was talking
about cuz I fact checked that 11.3% of
actually the population has diabetes
that's
pretty that's a lot
yeah man I got to invest in insulin
and
McDonald's invest in can we get a
McDonald's hamburger please and finally
with the insulin cooked into the
Patty you know I refuse will that work
that way it I don't know but the tech
that's it you know I see I refuse to
believe that we do not as a country have
the technology to to inject insulin into
French fries I mean if anybody can
figure it out it's going to be
McDonald's
yeah that'd be [__] okay let's watch
this let's watch it sorry yeah not not
diabetes and I will not I refuse to I'm
an Infidel I a
3 Infidel yeah yeah what does that me
what does she mean by that oh she's a
1ent or twoo oh oh [__] she's 1% of 3%
or how can you be both I guess why do
she say she's an Infidel that one's that
one is lost a person who does not
believe in religion or aderes to a
religious or other yeah I mean that's
just like the like maybe that's another
group yeah she's she's in a lot of group
she's got
groups I don't know okay Infidel thatal
4% and I
don't way doesn't work like that no it's
my America and I'm taking it back we're
going to have drop it off oh my God wait
what said we're going to have Trump in
office that's how musicals start like
are you kidding does someone want to sit
at the sound cuz I have request and
maybe somebody there I I mean I would I
would love to all right just no flockers
that's fine that you know what I mean I
I don't want to you know Zach is you
can't deal with the flockers it just I
figured there there was a reason I
wasn't
asked yeah I need to hear someone to
play
America actually yeah go ahead go ahead
go
ahead that's
America that's America to
me
[Music]
capella like the AC cappella that's
America
[Music]
o
she's got some pipes hold on the we need
to send this to Zach how have we not
seen this during Co no clue her
diaphragm is impeccable like that was
really great that was
Gorge to sound bite this what percentage
is she in I wondering for like vocals
you know she could be in another group
she's one or three but if you add them
it could it's
four man that was pretty on a grande was
perfect don't me I'll charge you she
just threatened to charge her on her
scooter I want her to I want to see it
so badly [__] she said don't touch me
I'll charge you she'll do it she'll sing
while it
happens hit that high
[Music]
SE I want to say these
poor workers during having to deal with
these psychos I cannot imagine what a
[__] job
mhm holy crap
[Music]
man what kind of this is from the
website Karen lives matter.com
America is this yes put it on Facebook
they're arresting me trying to P my
yeah on Facebook if I put it there I
need
[Applause]
myel I think Trump just found his new VP
wow
beautiful my God that was really
something I got to say this from three
months ago okay so maybe it's not it
must to be old The Mask nobody wears a
mask anymore no it's definitely from Co
era yeah
yeah there it is guys uh Walmart you
know Walmart is happening it's been
happening M the people that own Walmart
are one of the richest families in the
world they just [__] the Walton the
Walton no way are you serious no yeah no
it is it is that's where that's where
the Wall comes from walart look up the
Walton family wow why is that so funny
it's Walmart it's Walmart Walton it's
The Waltons Walmart net worth you want
to know how much these [__] people
are worth how these people I'll tell you
how much worth from selling
binders right they're estimated to be
worth $238 billion wow God bless their
heart wow the Walton family is followed
by the Mars family oh the Mars family
they just made a candy bar these people
made a candy bar and they're worth 160
billion wow people don't even like Mars
that much Mars is not that big it's big
in Europe it's massive Mars is also bars
it's not just the bars they own a bunch
show the candy bar Snickers Snickers
which you just asked hold on these candy
bars what I'm hearing are
overpriced oh yeah slash the prices on
these candy bars and frankly Walmart
what I'm seeing is we need to slash
these prices even deeper yeah 35 cents
they're overcharging 10
cents and they're definitely
overcharging at
Walmart I mean 238 bill
all right uh let's get uh Tom is on the
phone let's get to Tommy Boy because we
don't have all all day with him uh he is
busy all right one second let me get him
lined up he is busy man Hey Now ladies
and gentlemen there he is hey now hey
now love peace and love peace and love
peace and love Tom W for
Tom Tom you know that you know that
today is October 20th right I saw you
man I am a huge Howard fan do does the
H3 crew get the Howard reference yes
yeah yeah okay yes so uh peace and love
no more fan mail please
Tom so how you been since our last talk
you getting any I saw you you had a real
nice hit with uh that conservative guy
Patrick B David that one did good for
you right yeah it was good uh the H3
Community man shout out to you guys they
have been
unbelievable they are the best they are
the best like the day after I was all
with you guys I think I got 18,000
subscribers the next day really whoa
that's crazy that's
amazing thank you family I'm very proud
of our family we changed lives on a
daily basis Tom it's what we for real
they've been unbelievable and like
helpful and they got good suggestions
and they're just amazing you know what
I'm actually really hear that there is
like a really there's a group of like
the nicest sweetest people that are like
so supportive and they'll go and support
everyone the sweetest way so we love
them and we love you Tom well I love you
guys thank you thank you the feeling is
mutual of course uh how's the channel
going let me open it up real fast Tom W
video today we need views with plastic
surgery expert all right we need views
guys we need views Tom Ward show okay
well okay hold on it does look like it's
better though oh for
sure when I had you on you had ones that
had like 200 views oh yeah but I see on
much better the lowest one here is 2.8
th000 now I mean that's 10 times better
than how it was before and then Jimmy
Lee was a monster hit 10,000 weer how'
you connect with James
weiner uh he's persistent let say that
he reached out to you he came to
you oh that's [__] amazing D first of
all does he have your number because I
could see him just like oh you're on the
texting list did you give him your
number I'm on the texting list shout
out so sorry I I would never give him my
number I give him Zach's number and
mine uh he he DMS me on on Instagram and
it's just a constant barrage that check
in on and I don't always respond to I
usually don't respond to it because I
know what that leads to but I always do
read it Jimmy if you're watching and if
it's something that I feel you know I
want to reciprocate on I I do I do what
kind of how often does he text you Tom
no I was just kidding just h no he's
good just around the interview he was
like super he wanted to come on he was
like super
pumped yeah cuz I mean it's okay you can
say what you want about him he texts us
like 10 times a day yeah he's crazy yeah
no it's it's real it was an interesting
conversation for sure um wait did we
ever talk about he sent Howie that
picture of him in high school that post
yeah I don't think we did talk about the
show on we got to pull that
up had the funniest [__] post after
he did his Jimmy Lee interview yeah oh
maybe we did talk about on the show
actually we did I think so but I'll pull
it up either Jimmy now is texting him
nonstop and weird [__] too like he
texted him a picture of him in high
school shirt
L
yeah like
why and ho's caption was was wonderful
as well let's
see uh there it is Lonesome egg said uh
sub story time just found my fiance of
three years sending dick piics to other
people and my life feels over but you
make me smile and I love you all so much
shoot the son of a dick
pic that sucks what are we going to do
about Dick Pics man we got to curb
yeah we
got you know what I mean I'm sorry to
hear that
yeah uh get you get yourself a guy like
this instead look at Jimmy right this is
a monogamous so uh how we said we just
got sent this picture of Jimmy Lee from
years ago from Jimmy Lee nobody asked
for the picture Jimmy Lee can you please
send us a picture six months prior to
when this was
taken and he also sent another one oh my
God for those who have been waiting
since the last post here's the picture
of Jimmy Lee six months prior to the
first photo thank you all untoned I
can't tell yeah uh looks like the bottom
the Bottom's button but it's very all
chess me yeah yeah quite a bit he loses
a button every three months he is one of
a kind man so um uh well we brought you
on to basically um you know tap into
your
expertise uh we Rec called that you said
you are some kind of a appliance uh
professional is that
right yes correct I worked for a company
I've never Nam the company but the
company's called Hobart I worked for
them for like 10 years and they make I
think they were the biggest they make
these large commercial dishwashers
you'll see at like Cheesecake Factory at
busy restaurants and they make small
ones like all different sizes
flavors and then they make other stuff
too so I used to sell uh I did national
account so I used to sell like $8
million worth of stuff to
you I was okay eight million come on Tom
don't be
modest but like one one and a half per
year usually was dishwasher so I know I
don't know many things but I do know
about dishwashers okay so that's
interesting so you were selling the
industrial ones so those ones even more
than the residential ones would be
powerful
yeah um if they
so my question to you first of
all is do dishes need to be pre-washed
before entering the the dishwasher
y I mean I don't even know first of all
you did a poll what is the poll at right
now right we haven't put it up yet we
did one the other day and it was but in
your professional opinion Tom yes yeah
of course you do are you insane yes you
need to preent and I'll give you I have
notes okay oh interesting exactly why
you need the pre-wash it'll be over it's
a wrap go ahead
Tom number one if you go in the back of
any restaurant and if you watching this
you've ever worked in a restaurant
before go to the dishwasher station and
what is it there's a trash can where the
guy scrapes off the food and there's
this giant Hose Spray where they rewash
the dishes now they got these giant
powerful machines with like high-grade
chemicals and God knows what they're
putting on your plates to blast all this
stuff away why are they pre-rinsing
because the dishwasher won't get
everything off right so if you didn't
need to pre you know rinse why would
every restaurant have that that's one
okay number
two oatmeal
okay I eat a bowl of oatmeal every
morning all right I'm very
boring so I used to you know I used to
be in the camp where you don't pre-wash
so I would i' lazily put the bowl in the
dishwasher my wife runs the machine the
next morning she's yelling at me because
there's still oatmeal like concrete
crust oatmeal is a tough one okay and
EXA so you have to soak and pre-rinse to
get that off right if it was so great
that this dishwasher
technology hold on Tom hold on he can we
get the yep sound bite after every Point
yeah I'm I'm working on figuring it out
right now Tom I want to ask about
something you touched on you said you
have to soak the oatmeal I mean Tom how
long are we leaving that out for man it
depend I'm talking five minutes and it's
like concrete yes it's true if you don't
like put it in water right away it gets
stuck through the dish when I when I do
eat oatmeal I rinse it out immediately
when I'm done because you know that
thing is just going to be garbage if you
don't okay good you're going to have to
throw it uh like a like a
worthless Stone without Jade in it top
with peace and love okay go on Tom go on
peace and love peace and love example
and final
example is peanut butter have you ever
made a peanut butter and jelly s
absolutely who hasn't who hasn't okay
you put the peanut butter knife in the
dishwasher you run the dishwasher what
do you have
left you got a peanut buttery ass knife
damn right you do
e so maybe maybe is it possible that
this is a Nuance situation where some
materials should be soaked off or
pre-washed off but some materials don't
that is an excellent educated question
Ethan thank you okay of course you don't
need to pre-rinse everything okay you
eat a slice of pizza on a plate right
there's no mess there's no sauce on it
put in the dishwasher live your life
right right cuz a little marinara sauce
even I would think you could probably
just drop it in there a little marinara
you okay i' still R so Tom the
professional says yes you must pre-wash
the pole has drawn a very cisive
conclusion 80% the reason that we're
even talking about it is because you
read articles and we read articles by
professionals they say you do not need
to pre-wash in fact they even go as far
to say it's a waste of water it ruins
the efficiency of the dishwasher and
it's like ecologically horrible thing to
do pre-wash that's what they're telling
us the consumers and Tom a professional
with the biggest water drug I've ever
seen in my
life yes drink your water kid that is a
big ass [__]
how many what's the oun on that that is
a half gallon and notice I blacked out
the name of the water bottle because
[__] them they they gotta
pay all right they get no free
plugs smart man nothing and so um how
many of those you crush to day so I
drink a gallon to day so this is a half
gallon just drink two of those are you
frequent
Urinator I mean yeah you're drinking
[__] hell on award yeah what do you
think yeah just what I'm saying that's
that's the pro and con I guess of being
a dedicated H bro how bad do you have to
PE right
now okay so I'm good so here's what we
done by the way but not as big as not
even
close Okay so we've done a experiments
Dan has actually spearheaded the cause
Dan tell us about your methodology yeah
let me step in here for a second second
because I respect everything that you
have to say here Tom okay I respect you
Dan and about 72 hours ago I would have
been in full agreement with you however
H Something's Happened after that
article the other day I started to do a
little bit more digging into this whole
debate and I I've seen the code of the
Matrix now I've seen things I can't
unsee uh my eyes have been open so let
me go Point by point to the things that
you brought up first of all
you worked selling commercial
dishwashers now my understanding is that
commercial dishwashers one of the main
things that you're looking for in a
restaurant is speed right because and
cleanliness you can't C of course of
course on dirty plates of
even maybe it's sanitized but it's still
got smudges who wants a little you know
chips of smudges Dan mhm D well here's
the thing those machines correct me if
I'm wrong Tom but the cycle on those
machines are usually at most like 2
minutes right you rinse that thing off
you load up the tray you put it in there
you pull the thing down 2 3 minutes boom
you got clean PL okay that's interesting
yeah super quick not even that long
right wow and so oh they're designed to
be pre-rinsed because of that because
there's not really like a rinse cycle
even happening in there it's more like
it's just blasting it real quick and
then sterilizing it like like you said
with a bunch of chemicals and stuff if I
can uh interpret I think what Dan is
saying to you Tom and no offense these
are Dan's words that you might be out of
your
element I am not sir continue listen
listen that's a [__] point you got
to have clean plates so okay it's
industrial so what it's got to do it
quick yeah I agree but if it doesn't
quick and doesn't clean absolutely
that's a bad thing you don't want to
serve plates that are dirty to customer
I'm never and I'm not and I'm not gonna
argue with you on that point at all
because D is the queen nothing wrong dad
is the queen thank you thank you Rich
when it comes comes to commercial
dishwashers I I know that is not my area
of expertise and I I know I'm out of my
element so I think everything that
you're saying is perfectly valid okay
the issue is that we don't use
commercial dishwashers in our homes do
we we use consumer grade dishwashers are
designed with a very different set of
parameters in mind now the first thing
that my eyes were opened up to is I'm
curious in this room and I did a little
I did a little straw pull the other day
just amongst the crew but I'm curious
Tom Ethan and Ela if you have an answer
for this too what type of detergent do
you use and specifically do you use the
pods we do use the pods whatever you
want D the pods are dog [__] that's the
worst thing you could be using why tell
you I don't use pods so okay that's good
that's good about the pods you don't use
pods let me tell you let me tell you the
issue with the pods well the reason I
like the pods Dan is cuz I can snack on
one while I also H yeah so I'll tell you
exactly what the problem is let me let
me divert your eyes to exhibit a here
okay this this is my uh dishwasher at
home however this is very very standard
right yep now you'll notice right away
there are two trays here yes and then
you close the thing right and you likely
put your little pod right in there you
pop it in there and you close the thing
yeah but what about this one what is
this one doing this you probably can't
make it out but it says
prewash and what that is is when you put
your dishes in a dishwasher for the
first 15 minutes or so it is doing a
rinse cycle a rinse cycle that is
intended to be the rinse that you do on
your
plates if you do not have any soap in
that dishwasher or in that second little
thing then you're rinsing without any
soap hold on really you're saying that
with pre-wash somehow the water now is
going to magically remove peanut butter
and oatmeal from dishes okay I'm going
to get to the oatmeal point cuz there
there are obvious exceptions to this but
okay okay okay but as far as general
protocol of loading up your dishwasher
if you are not using the pre-wash you
can't blame the dishwasher for not
getting everything off of there because
you're not operating your machine
properly is the pre-wash is it pre-wash
a different product yeah what is no it
could just be regular detergent now you
see these little slots right
here those exist for a reason when you
lift up the door all of the soap that's
in this one drib out of these slots
again during the rinse cycle bro don't
be so vulgar
stop so so if you aren't using this then
again it's you're just kind of blasting
water around in there and yeah it's
going to get some stuff off but is it
going to get as much off as if it's
soapy water no no it's not thank you Dan
let me get my thoughts together here
okay so that's that's big Point number
one wait wait can we can we can we
rebuttal okay yeah of course Tom please
Dan I appreciate your passion but we're
not here to Grand stand we're here to
have a a friendly debate here or not
friendly sure yeah
absolutely rebuttal Tom okay thank you
um so I used to part of these training
is you have to this I mean it was the
boringest job ever you would meet with
Engineers who design dishwashers okay
and they're excited to talk to anybody
because no one cares what they do right
so they bore you to death I learned I
really didn't learn much from them but
what I learned is when they design these
machines they make them for idiots why
because we're all
idiots drun they they designed these
things to clean and they test them with
no detergent at all in them to see if
still get them clean so they know that
no one in the world puts pre-wash in the
machine they know that nobody uses the
machine right they for it and now now
let me let me just that is an
interesting point of clarification here
point of clarification here Tom uh these
Engineers that you're speaking to are
they working on Commercial dishwashers
or they're Universal dishwashing men
they do all types of dishwashers well
that's a good question right so the the
quick answer is yes but no the one
particular engineer I'm thinking of used
to work for Kenmore so he worked for
commercial and residential
dishwashers oh my God interesting
interesting that is a really interesting
uh
perspective although I I got to say I
think the proof is in the pudding I mean
of of the experiments we've conducted
let's see the the results okay well
obviously this is a very unscientific uh
experiment but I will um I will point
out that uh on Wednesday we had a big uh
food taste testing segment here on the
show uh Sam cooked up a number of dishes
for our friend love here uh to try out
yeah who is Sam um and um the uh the
issue is or not the issue is she she
loaded up all the dishes from the other
day in our dishwasher here at the show
did not rinse did it with the new
protocol that I called for and I got to
tell you these dishes if I can open this
damn picture here it
is I mean these things are spotless dude
I hope you got better photos than that I
have I have a number of photos here's
the here's the utensils specific concern
for the utensils warranted [__] gets
stuck between the little things it's all
kind of stacked it's like how well is it
going to do these I'm telling you you
can go look yourself this hasn't been
unloaded it's all sitting over there
Ethan if you want to verify looks clean
these are clean dishes clean dishes you
didn't find any not a speck I looked at
all of the plates not one spec on any of
them this is with the new protocol and
this is the type of dirty you would
expect that you would need to pre-wash
did you feel silly putting it in there
like there's no way this is g to work uh
well it was Sam that loaded it up but uh
she she was she was interested in
experimenting with this as well and uh
Sam can you answer that yeah go ahead I
felt silly you did okay I am very Pro
rinse but I was like okay I'm just going
to try it because I didn't know that
about the Rin cycle so I put some uh
sauce in the other little compartment
and it worked some sauce
is just real talent and people already I
see people pointing out the little spot
on the spoon I noticed that too it's a
little piece of rust that wasn't food
it's just it's on the spoon itself show
me again all right stand by stand
by okay uh where's the dang SP so s were
you um as a as a Avid
pre-wash were you con vinced by
this I
was Sam when you go home
interesting and you do your dishes at
home are you going to pre-rinse or no
after
this um my I don't think that my
dishwasher at home has that little
compartment is the thing not that I've
noticed they all do take a look because
I was skeptical at first and then I all
the ones that I've looked at since
having my eyes open like this sure
enough had had the same design not feel
good to not preent I have to say it's
not that bad I feel wrong you know and
what Tom is saying which I think is
important is that I don't think the
prein matters because they know you
ain't using
it
oh
[Laughter]
man there are some straight up weirdos
on the
internet
anyway uh so what you were basically
saying Tom that
um we they don't they know you're not
using the prein
now the what would you like to see cuz I
would like to see peanut butter I would
like to see syrup I would like to see
oatmeal okay so so oatmeal is one that
immediately came to my mind too and I'm
not going to tell you not to rinse your
your concrete oatmeal like obviously not
it's you know soak that but when it
comes to just a after a meal you know
you and the family you get up you take
your plate you scrape it off into the
trash you don't need to go to the sink
next straight into the dishwasher it's
okay it's okay it's not what about like
the dish that you mix raw egg in before
you cook an omelette that one raw egg
like the egg residue that'll come
that'll come right off in the dishwasher
that'll come right off dude it's sit
there and dry in the dishwasher cuz
you're not well are you going are you
going to are you going to not run the
dishwasher for a few days no you but all
it needs is like 30 minutes to dry I
think you'll be fine I think you'll be
totally fine the egg will come right off
Dan you would never you're just I'm
going to all right I'm going to live by
these words frankly I think we've come
across something interesting here mhm
but I do want to do more experiments
okay I want to
have some scientific method where we get
plates of varying degrees of
dirtiness and check them one by one
mhm on how well they were clear I think
we can do that and we can even we'll
even just for the sake of argument put
some oatmeal in a bowl let it dry for a
day and have that be one of the things
in there just just to see you maximize
the uh intensity sure egg too it'll be
like a allergy test you know how it's
like right where they stab the people in
the back what do you think about all
this
Tom I want to call in the question the
dirty spoon is it really rust trying to
P here
here we need to examine the spoon I
noticed those pictures were kind of low
res and a little far away then uh they
rightly should have been yeah correct
very suspicious yeah so Dan is fetching
the spoon we are calling the spoon into
question Dan is wow we got the whole
tray bringing the whole
tray right arranged in the same way and
I believe it's this spoon that was being
pointed to out of camera hold on hold on
but why did it look this this is this is
this the same spoon Tom yeah it's it's
got like it looks like the same SP this
gold color so let's
examine now I don't think this so was it
clean I don't think yeah it's clean I
don't think the silverware were super
dirty though right love no of course no
that's what I'm calling into question we
barely the food wasn't that dirty right
and they were little bites I would say
it's a standard mess no no we have a
picture of the dishes before they went
in sure uh oh no unfortunately not what
do you mean oh no how do we we do we do
in a sense because these dishes were
dirtied on the show so everybody saw
what was on the placeat they saw the
condition of the plates so it's not it's
not a total blind thing but I understand
that's a fair concern to bring up yeah
so that corn sule is really difficult
once it gets like dry it gets very
sticky to the pl sule I would say just
the corn sule alone you know what
another one I would say was probably
decent mess I was going to say the uh
the uh stuffed mushrooms cuz all that
melted cheese kind of overflowed onto
and hardened so we had like hardened
cheese on Place T cam while I go examin
or has it been emptied it hasn't been
emptied no so can I get a camera back
there uh if you give us a minute we
could do
that Tom I'm going to go back there and
check those plates one by one when do
you need to leave appreciate your
Dan yes yeah you got like five minutes
okay we're gonna we're gonna get on this
uh but hold on I can I can make a call
I'll be here if it's that important I
mean do are we gonna get an answer you
think well I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm going
to get there as soon as I can we're just
setting up the camera it should be ready
in any any moment now so
all right let me let me text somebody
but I'm gonna try my hardest I don't
think you'll need that much time if you
have something urgent to do you know
what I mean no I'll be
okay so again I I do believe although I
I do find the the preliminary evidence
compelling I find that the methodology
was lacking frankly we need more
evidence
yeah
oh I'm going to go look at the
dishes I have a
miced up yours which kind of like
doesn't help your case then
no
suspicious for
sure okay we hear him rustling over
there I do hear the dishes he's going
through the plates lots of crinkling
lots of trying to
Breaking something could definitely
break it sounds
like what is possibly going on what is
he doing going ham on these
plates he's he can look he can look I'm
telling you this thing for [__] clean
dude another thing I wanted to bring up
is you didn't make this objection Tom
however this was an objection that was
talked about the other day on the show
and I see all over the Internet that if
there's a bunch of food on the plates
and it gets sprayed off in the
dishwasher where's that food going it's
going to clog the thing up right if you
just have a bunch of like chunky food in
there wrong the drain on a residential
uh dishwasher has a food a garbage
disposal built into it it chops up yes
when does it do that at the at the drain
where at the very bottom of like the
Basin there's blades in there never
heard that and when it spins it's
chopping up everything that goes into it
there's blades in there there's blades
in your dishwasher bro I didn't know
either this is why I was saying so I
look I examined the dishes fairly fairly
well they are all clean okay spotless
frankly but again we need more Tom I
think we need to we need to do here's
what I want to do Tom okay I think the
the early analysis is interesting but
it's lacking
methodology as I described I want to set
up a more comprehensive test and I would
like
uh to bring you back to analyze that
when we're ready to take it to the next
ST which will maybe hopefully be next
week can I have your number so I can
text you about this
abely you can text Jimmy he's gonna blow
us up Jimmy style yeah Tom it's great to
see you yeah thank you Tom thank
you and it's all love Tom peace and love
happy October 20th to you peace and love
peace and love peace and love subscribe
W show talk to you next time bye that's
Tom Ward everybody byebye dishwashing
expert who is
Team pre-wash now let's do another poll
to see if the needle has moved again I
do Wonder okay I
think next
week we can really Drive some good
data H we need pictures before and after
of every dish right yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think I think like you said uh maybe
two plates like 10 different like
residues so to speak each one twice so
that we're thorough so like two stuck
with oatmeal two covered in grease two
with this or whatever and then we load
it up and no rinsing see how it goes
yeah okay [__] I got to
say Dan's been evangelizing around the
office all week and he's changed my mind
on it and I don't even have a dish it's
just not enough it's just not enough I I
think the early results are interesting
but us in the scientific Community we
have to be rigorous we have to cross
check before we come out with with fact
finding and and uh proclamations because
frankly if this does turn out to be true
not only could it be a generation
defining Discovery it might even win a
Nobel Peace Prize oh so it's important
that we we take this seriously you move
the needle a little bit a little bit a
little bit I think it's I think that's
actually significant it it is
significant agree yeah it is significant
it's still obviously clear
majority
um I mean look the thing is like of
course it will clean some
plates the question
is how many and to what degree well
here's a counter question do you
pre-rinse all of your dishes not all of
them no some you do just pop right in
there yeah right so we're just we're
talk we're we're in the margins here you
know what I mean it's like not quite Dan
because again we're saying you don't I
think the claim was you don't need to
pre-wash period no exceptions and you're
talking to me about putting an egg I'm
not going to put my reputation on the
line you said to me Dan I will put a
bowl which I scrambled eggs in in the
washer with that one I think it could
handle that one I think it could handle
I'm mostly just concerned about real
stuck on [__] like oatmeal or or other
grains that get like that hardened like
concrete you're probably going to need
to do a little extra love on those Dan
good luck and you furthermore you're
asserting that if you've got like let's
say you got a play with like I don't
know lasagna and all this sauce and [__]
so you scrape it off scrape it off
there's there's like a fair amount of
food there's going to be some chunks on
there but you scrape it off tons of [__]
still little not you know what I mean
the the bulk of it is gone but there's
still a lot there put it in put it in
there the dishwasher not a problem cuz
what would you do otherwise you probably
wash it in your sink with your garbage
disposal and then run the garbage
disposal you're effectively you're just
doing that twice you're just doing that
twice at that
point the thing that really sold it for
me Dan was that video you showed me
where somebody cut like a hole in their
washer and was window and I want to
shout that guy out uh uh he's somebody a
YouTuber that I've watched for a long
time actually uh his Channel's called
technology connect
and uh when I started going down this
Rabbit Hole I looked to see if he had a
video about it and sure enough he had
amazing one where he cut a piece of
plexiglass in the side of a dishwasher
and then ran a cycle to show what's
going on in there and when you see what
it's doing during that Sprint cycle up
you want to see yeah just show me that
that clip you're talking about you need
the visual this is this is compelling
stuff technology shout out and let's
pull it up roll it you know you may have
seen him before he's he's pretty big
YouTuber actually uh
dishwasher
uh these okay here's the video and let
me find the part where it shows it shout
out to uh
Dan Dan is searching for the plexiglass
dishwasher it I think this is it thanks
Ethan he's replaced the door with a
plexiglass yeah he's like cut a metal
chunk out of the side of it and put
plexiglass there so you can see
operating on the inside and when you see
these high powerered Jets and you
realize it's it's hot water with with
detergent if you load it properly
Suddenly It's like yeah that probably is
getting stuff off just as well as I
would be able to do in a sink way better
than a sink I know the thing is like if
you have a plate that's sideways cuz I
see lots of like up and down motion mhm
I'm not seeing tons of side to side
motion anyway shout out to technology
connect you guys want to learn more
rules about that okay so we have more
work to do we have more work thank you
thank you to everybody thank you
L dude I I couldn't help it when Gabe
called and I when it cut to Tom looking
super
[Laughter]
confused well I was just going to leave
it on Gabe but I saw his little window
over here that he was just blankly
staring you had to cut um that was
so
important um okay great there it is
there it
is uh up
next
somebody you guys remember we talked
about on Wednesday this weird Alpha kid
yeah made a
video saying that I'm a dumbass that
only talks about cats cats yeah and
somebody out there in the crowd one of
you
monsters spent a lot of [__] time
putting this video together and managed
to crop every time I've mentioned a cat
in my whole
career and it does total the amount of
two minutes and 40 seconds oh that
that's not the whole thing that includes
his Tik Tok so maybe more like
230 which I got to say over like a 10
plus year span that's not a lot of cat
talk here it is demented in his brain
they talk about the most likeed [__] he
talks about like cats bro and all this
dumb [__] like bro people who watch that
I literally look at it as like you're
microwaving your body you're microwaving
your brain your thought process that's
the thing that you drew on that I talk
about cats I mean there's so many things
I do talk about that are off color cats
is one I can't say that I've talked a
lot about not a frequent topic of
conversation on this show showing you
photos for my life my cat my kid my
bacon my cat Russia thing is is
fascinating to me that's not fair I
that's just like you're reading
something right yeah yeah hold on that
was the crime and then what is this cat
is fascinating to me hold on I refute
these my cat my kid my bacon my cat this
Trump Russia thing is C is fascinating
to
Me Maybe maybe that's maybe that's what
he saw cats are your Roman Empire it
fascinating to me bitting it's twirling
it's got a cat it looks like they wrote
on it with a sharpie don't eat that
that's toxic she doesn't give a [__]
it's Elsa was he in cats he was in he
was in cat he was in The Wire he's been
in a lot of stuff known for cats I
didn't know as he was the mean the big
cat the end right did you like the movie
no okay no he talks about like cats bro
and all this dumb [__] this the beverage
no at the bottom oh it's the 90day
fiance guy oh it's a cat I see the cat
here
like if a black cat crosses the road I
will not drive that way cat that was
Z still on your show your show it's your
show dude bro they just spent all day
talking about
cats it's so awesome oh man I want to
talk to each one of these guys did he
did we ever reach out to
him we concluded that we weren't
interested really yeah change your mind
change your mind I love talking to
them we can
I think I I think I did uh let me check
Tik Tok I think I may have DMD him there
cat let's
see
uh no bro are you [__] high right now
you should send him you should send him
meow for your
message we weird M meow it's a voice
message meow meow
daddyy sorry that kid's too young
that's a James Charles
thing I don't know what his age is but I
ain't meowing at
him yep I'll mow at you
girl look at that cat looks like a loaf
of bread never seen a cat shaped like
that I like him I'm not saying I don't
like the cat I'm just saying he's you're
noty Cordo boy just look at him so
defensive that's a good reaction though
Dan thank you you say I like him I like
them that's transformative nice I like
this does anyone not like this that
could help transform maybe you I can't I
can't continue it's too to
see he was so right yeah and I feel like
an idiot now I'd say apologize but you
destroyed the podium so there's really
no
way when we get another a Podium apology
Podium apology if that does happen
you'll be the
first to receive my uh condol I'll add
him to the list does that make sister
sense uh we this guy who nared his
butthole and balls and all that um right
he's been talking about me did you know
about this Ela I do know about it so
first I saw
this and then I was like oh my God I
like this guy he said he called me hot
as
[__] and I was like okay this guy's
great guy is
terrific let's get some more butthole up
man yeah I support you get it fetish
eyes white men well I like Jewish men
the most I don't know if they're white
well you usually say giving trishia a
lot ashkanazi I don't think they're
fully white you no do you know do you
know what that means ashkanazi Jewish
well they like look like not white white
no they look white they're they do not
they're from Central and Eastern Europe
no it's from Israel no Kevin I had a
feeling you didn't really know what it
meant I thought it was Israeli Einstein
Albert Einstein is Jewish oh look up the
hot men though cuz I don't want to see
like old women I mean I love old women
but he is asazi yeah he's hot as [__]
white I guess I do like white people I
do but does that mean I don't like
blacks no I didn't ask what a
conversation okay so he says I'm hot as
[__] yeah I am as an ashkanazi
Jew H as [__] I think he was describing
you cuz he's like it's it seems like you
had somebody in mind it is kind of an
interesting question because this is a
kind of a ongoing debate if Jew Jews are
white for well it depends who you're you
I think would technically I'm Safar yeah
you're you're you technically be like
Middle
Eastern more Arabic frankly cuz your
your spoke Arabic
yeah so you are not white but maybe
white passing definitely white passing
but like I don't know it's such a weird
question is it not white well it's all
it is all quite silly to be honest
because what does it actually mean it
includes so many
different ethnicities but I don't think
you have white I guess like he was
saying in this video it's like you know
European Russian whatever got it of
descent and I don't think you have you
do have some Italian though actually but
majority you're Middle Eastern
PC
precisely princess
of I'm not going to finish the sentence
cut them off anyway so that wasn't the
only one of him uh begging me up thank
you by the way I see people in chat
saying my rash is back my face [__] up
dude I'm tired of
it I got to sit here in front of a
camera looking like like this what the
[__] man what the [__] dude have you
been doing anything about it though I'm
I am curious I did a lot about it yeah
and then it you know with the
Dermatology gave me all those creams I
did it for four weeks and the minute I
stopped it all came back [__] and then
she gave you a new schle got worse too
when it came back it got worse because
and then I think it was cuz the steroid
cream so I went off the steroid cream
and then it actually did get better
and now just in the last few days it
started to get worse again so
weird but I guess I do need to see a
dermatologist again but it's not
something you always had I don't know
why no it's new that's why it's Lucas
related yeah that's the only explanation
at this point in my opinion right I mean
it's that and the age really those two
together age they you're within the age
group right 18 to 45
MH where we all may have Lupus frankly
[Music]
yep uh here's another clip from uh my
new favorite guy although this one I'm
going to contest a little bit anyone
who's actually watched these videos him
naring his butthole and balls will
know uh just what I'm talking about in
this clip but here let's let's
listen for sexual
gra hold on let me refresh here
doing this for sexual gra
okay this is why I show I knew it was
going to trigger you if I was I would
have an only fans by now cuz I would
plug my only fans and get people to
subscribe to tr believe that it's for
educational purposes only and nothing
it's for comedic purposes too it's funny
so you're not trying arouse no if you
watch me and you get aroused something's
wrong with you you're not trying to be
sexy no I'm not if I was I would have an
only fans and I would plug that every
single time it's annoying cry about it
babes I'm just kidding he's he he's
given it away for free frankly that is
interesting so here's what I'll say I do
wonder why not Mak an only fan yeah at
that point he's showing the whole damn
thing yeah uh well maybe you know maybe
he he's about educating people he's
here's what I'll say after having seen
those
videos he is funny he seems like a funny
dude but
I also got to tell you dude there's
definitely a lot of [__] people
watching that for sexual
gratification there's got to
be right I'm dick you're doing fetish
content bro you are I mean maybe it's
50% funny 50% fetish content is a man's
dick balls an
[__] it's hilarious he's doing a
service to people who want to learn I
guess
that's what he says do you really need a
do you need instructions on how to Nar
your butthole his instruction were this
put the n on your butthole wait wipe it
off that's what the bottle says okay
what about he's making art men they're
doing impossible argument I would
respect that more okay I I think I'll
I'll argue that I think it's
theater I think it's
beautiful I think it's shocking what
what happened
shocking it moves that is for sure have
you ever it's he's like a modern uh John
Waters in a way that's a pretty extreme
joke too by the way like it's not okay I
I'm telling you you don't you don't
understand unless you've seen the video
it literally jump cuts from him being
like all right so guys today I'm going
to show you how to nare uh your butthole
and then immediate cut to the camera
like 1 in from his hairy [__] it was
a per
awward was like the funniest way he
could have done that with his balls on
displaying out there it's so so so much
he very
brave very brave he's he is very brave
but yeah you're giving it away for free
brother anyway he seems like a funny
dude I'm not even that annoyed at him to
be honest it's kind of YouTube he's just
using the system [__] but right if he
didn't do it someone else would the fact
that he says it's comedy and necessary
service I'm already taking my pants off
does show just how silly YouTube is
being like that is not educational
content sorry but okay whatever and I've
had a verified 18yearold uh account
since I was like 10 how did you do it I
don't remember I just [__] clicked
yes I'm 18 oh that's back in the days at
least but I don't know I'm guessing
there's a little bit more to it now but
I don't think there's much more to it so
to make a YouTube account make a YouTube
account and there's no like real air
veric yeah you can just put anything
Surly yeah oh okay yeah yeah so my
theory is that it's very easily
accessible to Children which That's my
kind of I mean if I was in Middle School
or high school I would definitely send
that to people
yeah you know like when I was in Middle
School the goatsy was the pick that
everyone was sending goatsy two girls
one cup and the good thing about that is
you're getting a YouTube link you don't
expect to see dick and ass
but you do you get the YouTube you go it
must be safe you're sitting in a dental
office you're sitting at a family
reunion you see the YouTube link what
could how bad could it be you click it
you're talking to your grandma she's
looking over your shoulders [__] and
Dick and hair it's funny by the way that
video has 46 million views really
yeah so is that people just sending it
to their friends or what or is it people
it went really viral I mean that's why
we all heard about it right
right I mean the guy found a niche what
can I say yeah he did and that Niche is
in his butthole also I'm reading it's
not recommended to use nare for your
[__] he had a sensitive one that oh
yeah but I guess so I would call that
false advertising can you use the
sensitive one on your butthole let me
Google it
yeah they'd probably say no but you know
where else is it
for there is risk for Burns and severe
allergic reactions and that's why you
shouldn't use it on your private it
works you
guys see these medicine commercials on
TV they
go do not
take these medicines have the craziest
names I me I can't even recall one
praxias some [__] like that do not take
praxias if you're allergic to praxias no
[__] if you know what I mean I got to
take it to figure it out that they
always say that
and it pisses me off
dude I can't stand watching the
commercials medicine commercials are the
worst they should be illegal here it
seems like it's all medicine it is like
especially daytime TV it's literally and
you can't even buy it this is how
lucrative is for them they go go tell
your doctor you want this that's what
they say right ask your doctor ask your
tell your doctor to give you this [__]
most countries that's illegal not
America all right moving on just got a
pretty interesting member shot is they
say my 10-year-old niece saw it which I
feel
like yeah they the person well listen 46
million people watched it I mean I was
being there's a ton of kids saw that
video for
sure but you can't just let it slide
please sometimes you just got to see a
but a hairy
butthole I guess that's part of the
growing up
process that's a joke kids don't need to
see
that thanks thanks Ethan
kleene uh we've
got Cav Cav made a really weird drunk
video he did on triller which is so dead
by the way why are you so cute when you
talk [__] I went to triller's website
ONN and the website was barely
functional let's go find it on triller
I'd like to watch it in the source if I
can
triller uh let me plug your company Ryan
triller because I'm the only one I'm the
only one talking about this
website you should be paying me dude for
promotion not suing me what is this
website does rank K look like Harvey wi
stream clicked it cuz I typed his name
clicked it spent some time on it looked
at the
photos I can't even find his trailer
account cuz he's such a
nobody yeah I feel like it's not going
to come up like that all right let me go
to triller.com
I just sent it what is this they didn't
even get triller.com Ursula
triller wait what some some journalist
has triller.com they couldn't even get
it from her that is so funny dude like
what a pathetic business is that and I'm
sure they offered her money and she just
stood not enough yeah that's awesome so
wait what is the domain filler. Co yeah
I link the video if you want to hold on
the idea that they're trying to
launch a social media to supplant Tik
Tok and become the biggest social media
in the United States maybe the world and
they they can't they're not buying the
triller.com
too much wine sorry is so funny holy
[__] uh let's see Ryan kavanau let's
look him
up man I just don't know how much longer
they can keep this website open so
doco is
that upco is an internet country code
top level domain assigned to
Colombia exactly yeah they got that got
that good
Colombian I mean obviously you can use
it anywhere but that's I gu what it
primarily is used for oh man that's
hilarious so let's see here's the recent
one I see he's picking his thumbnails
really good crazy what opening here you
know if you ever want to know the
capabilities of triller look no further
than the co-founder I can't do that what
is happening co-founder of triller says
right here in the description he has no
profile picture nothing more fun or
cooler ever he says dude is he he's
literally a s this is him inventing
firefighting I think
oh nothing more fun or cooler ever more
fun or cooler ever is that even like a
correct sentence I mean maybe for 12y
okay he posted a vertical video or a
horizontal video and a vertical app too
yeah which one is that no that's this
video
is is this the one here it is I check
this out this is ang this
is God no co-founder of
triller media Dynamo tycoon in
sepia Ryan
Kavanaugh
day
F exuse me there's apparently lots of
angels
around
huh what I'm yeah it's Angel
day Angel day to
much [__] white angel day but I'm
drunk I don't know oh he's I feel smack
second smack dude I don't even know if
he might be on something even tarer
this worried he
seems I am worried listen all I'm saying
is obviously conjecture I I don't know
I'm just saying Behavior seems erratic
and weird we're just concerned for him
yeah genuinely and I I don't know if
he's has the competency even to uh bring
a case to court I think he's [__]
stupid yeah let me finish watching
this and third
smack and that's about all the smacks I
could
take another Angel day is that Brad
that's bread
everywhere we live why are they together
like this he's babysitting him dude dude
there [__] is going on on mushrooms or
something like what the the fact that
they hang out so much is so interesting
like when do you ever lounge with your
home I haven't lounge with my homie like
this since I was like in high school or
something let alone your your wife's
ex-husband and what were you guys doing
together playing video games yeah
getting high getting high right you're
right exactly
couch angel
angel thanks for taking care of her
Brad's not even responding to this
psycho
[__] Brad's got too much dignity and
self respect to get involved in this I
don't know what happened in the Angels
but I D I can't believe what I'm
watching wait what the [__] wait it's
not Brad oh Weir what the hell oh
somebody else cuz he tagged BR Brad the
in description there
yeah where always closing oh that's his
Brad that's
BR dude Brad is like the guy from
American Beauty that is like just [__]
everyone cuz he's so cool and awesome
you remember the realtor that [__] his
wife always closing he was also a
realtor always closing baby
[__]
m
a bro put the camera down crazy
[__] my eyes look
dilated all do my eyes look dilated he
has to be on something he's on something
real heavy yep yeah he's off the smack
I'm guessing when I say I he's must be
I'm guessing I don't know anything of
course we don't know anything about this
this is all specul ative my wife except
well what's not speculative is that Brad
did [__] his
ex-wife well we don't know that about my
wife in this context yeah he's also like
using verbage that is like I'm high my
look at are my pupils dilated like
you're kind of letting me know exactly
what's going on are you saying that
there's a chance that him his Brad the
bull and his wife and his ex have not
consummated I mean I haven't been in the
room with them I we don't know what
happened if he wants to sue me we're
going to have to do a discovery on
that you know what I mean h get a camera
in there makes sense why you worried
about my wife maybe it's just
me okay that feels better though dude
why did you post feel better I'm the
question is why is it still up D nobody
saw it it's got 160 views nobody's on
this website
[Laughter]
that is a cool filter actually yeah if
he wasn't like your enemy I would think
this is a funny
video concerning though yes absolutely
very concerning like somebody get your
dad um so that's Ryan Kavanaugh that's
what he's up to is he going to erase
this now that uh we've seen it so then
after this one he posted the the
horizontal one with the big text and the
this one yeah nothing more fun or cooler
ever dude you Wen so did he hit his head
knew did he hit his head I mean he might
have banged his head when he crashed
into a police uh car when he was
drunk I think that happened right that
was speculate
speculated uh that he hit yeah I think
that [__] well let me see what's
written on the website cuz that stuff's
all pretty fast back checked yeah which
website are you referring to yeah I'm
just going to go type
Ryan
Kavanaugh spell his name out right go
down go down go down it's number three
today oh
interesting oh yeah just send me the
source Camp thanks y third paragraph
there okay so so I was I was just uh
citing the New York Times article very
reputable Mr Cavin charged with driving
car that sideswiped a Los Angeles Police
Department crew
news was he drunk was that something
that was part of this who know I mean
uh okay so may where does it say that oh
actually sorry I'm Mis reading the
article the paracraft just before it
says why put on fake news to try to
cancel me it's just that there is a yeah
under the influence of alcohol yeah no
there was alcohol involved shoot oh
shucks 19 months ago Mr was arrested by
a sheriff's department officer who
accused him of driving under the
influence of alcohol and being involved
in a hit and run he's charged with
driving a car that sideswiped the LAPD
officer so maybe he banged his head this
is big
news you
know he's a good guy we like Ryan we're
all rooting for him we're all rooting
for we're all rooting for him this is
big news new triller dual cam everybody
everybody get over here triller's got a
new
feature we're going to make it showing
off the new triller cam the first major
company to have two cameras built into
one no way your own MC anywhere you go
what does that I want to tell you about
my backyard my dogs two of my five you
do not deserve
that and uh just you know jeez man he
looks rough that lighting is not
flattering definitely you can see the
wrinkles in that Jesus Christ this
lawsuit has not been has not aged him
well
cuz I want to make sure that you guys
can hear me clearly I bet he's got some
big
old the hillside can't really tell in
the picture but that's the oce the Getty
set is pretty oh my God he lives really
close to
us you say that wait I wonder if he's on
okay I I'm not going to get I don't know
where he is but yeah we I mean we live
near the Getty no we don't
okay what are you talking hold on pause
the mic mute the
mics you know how to do that Dan yeah
okay stick your
funger I'm sorry I wasn't paying
attention I guess people were worried
that I was giving my I was like did you
guys forget that like the minute we
moved there was like a massive uh
headline I literally made a video being
like here's where I live you know that
this is not see you next Tuesday right
every I'm just saying it's it like you
know okay fair enough yeah we live near
the Getty
stop theti I never heard of that
place uh yeah you want to meet Athena
that's Athena that's Zeus hi
Athena you aw I don't get the point of
the two cameras to be honest with you
dude he's the they're the first major
company to ever have two cameras like
why do I need a window inside window
what's the point wasn't that a um a
trend with another app yeah I real right
there was right yeah there's a few but
yeah so he's lying well we don't know
when this video was posted but something
tells me they're not the cooler that
something tells me probably not the
first they're say interesting dialogue
going on here somebody left a comment
this is from May 2022 they said damn DN
this app is [__] that's so weird hold on
somebody has an account [__] Ryan
Kavanaugh that's not cool come on or
well maybe they're from something else
Kevin not it's not
him maybe because he has a lot of he has
a lot of animes he has done he has
wronged a lot of people yeah who's to
say where that came from isn't his Nanny
suing him right now or something for not
paying yeah Nanny suing his exwife at
least at one point she was we don't know
the status of that his ex his Nanny was
suing threatening suit cuz he hadn't
paid her like wages in a long time
according to the this this new one that
was
um that was alleged is really intense
it's like his ex-wife or girlfriend or
something accused him of like abusing
her kids what a [__] piece of [__]
dude you can pull it up though so I'm
not speaking at a
turn but uh he's going through a lot
you know both good
dogs that's M feel bad for him to be
honest I feel bad for him I mean me too
yeah for sure I this is the first time I
felt bad for Ryan but this guy like this
is
sad I don't know man H I'm sorry Ryan we
just got to get we just got to get you
help man we just got to get you
better we're all rooting for
you
here's the yeah thank you oh God what is
that Hollywood exec sued by babysitter
and wage spat yeah this one and then
what was the other one I'm I'm trying to
find the most recent one I'm seeing so
many
l he's prolific in that regard yeah yeah
there's a lot to read about him it's a
lot to say in fact his Wikipedia page is
very
comprehensive very
comprehensive uh okay Ryan
so I don't know I'm I'm real worried
about
him this is awesome at
this oh [__] holy moly y I thought
Harvey Weinstein was in jail someone
said no he is you're right that's not
Harvey Weinstein Harvey Weinstein is in
jail if Ryan kavanau Goes to Jail then
it will be really
confusing cuz how you going to tell him
apart the guy in jail okay they're both
in
jail tough
call I do want to I do want to make sure
I get the facts straight though AB on
the um yeah I'm looking into it yeah
yeah the first website I finally found
it I need to pay for he also put out a
statement that basically uh summarizes
it all too but there it is C Cav shout
out we're all rooting for you buddy we
really are and guys I don't even think I
need to say this because I've said it so
many times and I know you guys know do
not harass Ryan or anyone he knows for
me I do not want you to do that ever do
not bother Ryan stay on the side of the
glass do not exactly don't don't stay on
this side of the glass don't go leave
comments don't do anything leave the man
alone thank you speaking of leaving him
alone um let's see here action against
variety's billion dollar producer well X
Ryan Kavanagh takes legal action against
oh so he sued them for suing
him okay fun uh this is from this year
may let's see prominent entrepreneur
Ryan
cavcav uh he provided intimate details
of the supposed scheme of his
ex-girlfriend and Her counsel her lawyer
he's accusing the PA of attempting to
defame him and his uh profession so he's
suing them for defamation too we got to
link up attempted defamation we need a
support group for Real uh following her
failed Endeavor to land a
job there's claims of sexual harassment
uh she
claimed yeah
yeah oh this this seems like a press
release because it's all like in a
seemingly calculated move with her
current lawyer her third thus far it's
like okay how much were you paid has it
led you want to talk about Thro who
wrote this article wait what is the look
at the title of the
article varieties billion dollar
producer varieties okay who's Tom white
this guy's paid I think I found this
section you're talking about yeah he's
not a varieties
producer yeah this seems weird the
accusations Encompass new uh now more
than 2 years later and never before rais
claims of sexual harassment when that
didn't work to include drug use and
finally uh after a week of threats when
it became clear Kevan all wasn't going
to give in to their extortion even
reached as low as concerning child
endangerment claims so those are all the
claims yeah dude he what what the [__]
is this
article holy smoke that title is very
confusing no no no look I don't want to
do this on the show but look at Tom
white he's a paid for play guy right we
we almost certainly remember we uh it's
even real we've we've seen Ryan doing
that many times before
allegedly allegedly no it was like no no
not allegedly he was been on all those
like for like mailers yeah exactly
Instagram competitions right oh
okay that's
right all right well Tom white has a
really prolific career over here John
mcer Shar John mcer shares the secret to
making eight figures in real estate wait
the [__] up and popular shopping app
tenmo makes big game debut so check out
his uh body of work
there all right now that that's all
cleared
up Stephen has a new song I'm
rectangular oh yes he made a new song
that's kind of going viral I listen to
it so and it's is it claimed or no no I
wish was oh no this is all he got why
this should have more
views this is such an
iconic okay so when I first saw this I
was like oh wow he got a private plane
or something for it but as he continues
to walk it no he's just magnetic he's
actually just doing this I wish you
would come closer come closer to me wait
did the beginning start with I
traveled uh the other there's two videos
of this magnetic song the other one
starts with the oh so let me watch that
one though sure if that's the more
comprehensive yeah that's the official
version yeah I traveled
1,447 Kish to Magnetic Hill for this I
wish it was mag magnetic hey what
happened it wasn't synced up at all was
it look at his mouth hold on hold on let
me go back is this just a sync thing Dan
or Play It Again audio is slightly delay
this is to Magnetic Hill for this I wish
it was magnetic magnetic what the [__]
what do you why didn't he trim it or
something wish come closer okay so he
just started too early and didn't want
to retake it magnetic
magnetic I wish you would come close
closer come closer to me and if I had my
way and I got close to you you get stuck
to Me exra Passion
here I wish I was magnetic
magnetic I wish you would come closer
come closer to me and if I had my way I
got close to you you get stuck to me so
so hold on he's a rectang he's a he's a
rectangular magnet I think rectangles
are out
stop well hold on what shape are most
magnets it could be any shape could this
song sounds like it's in the shape of a
heart SE cires though too but I I've
noticing a trend in his music it's like
I am this thing I am I am a rectangle I
am a magnet right I am
a I am a uh I'm not suicidal right
whatever whatever what the meaning I
think he just needs to be
himself he's trying to be someone else
be something else MH Sean you're not a
magnet bro you're not a rectangle you're
a man you're a human being with complex
emotions and ideas very very mixed
response in the chat I must say song
well watch this I wish was magnetic
magnetic cuz I know this one Clos closer
just because the whole main if I had my
way and I got close to you you get stuck
to me
that lyric is a little a little wish was
little bad VI like you get stuck to me
like against your will a little bit
little this is what it gives me here
let's listen again cuz you're absolutely
right
[Music]
closer I'm going to have my way with you
oh
no listen to the lyrics I just want to
point out depending on the uh way you
have the magnet he could actually be
repelling everybody with his magnetism
actually wait but that's not what he
says though I'm just trying to give him
an
out that's M up it's just an unfortunate
lyric I think I don't know any other way
to interpret that closer come closer to
me and if I had my way and I got close
to you you get stuck to
me that is the only way to interpret
that I'm sorry he delivers it in a
Sinister manner let's be honest he goes
you'll get stuck to me it's giving um
you never leave it's just it's scary a
little bit also like the way he's
cruising through the public without out
of care makes him feel like I don't care
about anything but getting you and in a
sense it's giving me handcuffs to a
radiator you know right
what wish was
magne this poor kid man look at
this this
kid my God this guy's in the so Anno it
looks like he must be getting close to
like the
[Music]
bathroom look at all the people he's
just I wish was magne excuse me I'm
shooting a music
video look at the poor kid
here wish you would so hold on what's
also funny to I think he by the way his
arm is angled he must be doing a selfie
stick yeah for sure so that makes it
even
weirder do you think he he has to go
first class surely did he go back to
economy and record this I think he
probably would yes he would cuz he's a
multi-millionaire that's an interesting
point so he went back to the he would
have shoot this In First Class they'll
kick you oh yeah for sure you would do
this he wants to be back yeah he want to
be like relatable and all I think that's
a good point I guess now he's just
having a
big though this plane doesn't look like
it's really small looks like it's all
that's true maybe there isn't a first
class there's in this there's economy
Plus for sure though that's for
sure plus more leg
room my way and I got close to you you
stuck to
me
it it you would be
awesome wish I wish it ended with him
going in the bathroom that's what I
agree that's what I feel like that would
have made it so funny I feel like I'm
missing that shot like he he's walking
towards the bathroom he just got a pee
and he just shot this on the way yeah
that would make wait it would also give
us a story like maybe he's waiting for
someone in the airplane to meet him
there he's like if I had my way you'd
you'd come meet me maybe that's the
concept Hello Olivia but I want to
uplift uh Stephen I think he's got a
beautiful voice frankly I agree with you
I think he needs help with the lyrics if
I may say he like his lyrics are it's
not that they're bad it's catch though a
little he definitely knows outside
perspective definitely knows how to make
a catchy song yeah sure like I like the
concepts are cool like the rectangular
and the magnet are nice concepts for a
song he just needs a little out door a
little outside press would be like this
sounds like rape dude do you want to
change this
up now that phone down I don't know I
mean everybody look at your phone right
now it's also worth mentioning a a
industrial strength magnet on a plane
would be very bad oh true would be very
bad dangerous yeah that's you can't
allow that don't show the screen thanks
what are you afraid
of uh I pulled up our lunch spot that's
what I'm afraid of
ah you want this spot I'm not sure about
it it you feeling it I'm not feeling it
it like a lot of meat it's all meat no
it's healthy this is healthy yeah you
can get veggies instead of the that
thing it's so good I just not know oh
well I can maybe I could do this what do
you think about this yila think that
about this I don't like rice it's like
all rice you I don't have a plan I think
I'm the only person doesn't like rice I
hate to say it but it's true what is
this uh edit
of Magneto that's Magneto he's in his
villain Arc right now oh
Magneto oh that would be so cool if that
was like a solo performance by Magneto
in one of the
movies like a breakdown where just turns
into
music yeah that would be really like he
lost his powers and he's in the Dark
Knight of the Soul trying to uh find
himself I watch X-Men musical for sure
yeah he's really complex interesting
character honestly so him having that
gentle side would would fit with the
character anyway shout out to Sean
Stevens who shout out shout out keep it
up he is out there y he is out there
he's creative he's magnetic he's tra
he's traveling thousands of K you'll get
stuck you know what we're at 3:30 so we
should
probably get to the poem segment then
the Sniper Wolf stuff we just have so
much fun stuff to watch here yep uh one
thing I do want to welcome back is the
seamen preacher real fast King Master
Prophet uh
Seaman uh no this isn't the Seaman's
another type of milk Guy this is the uh
you guys will recognize his voice he has
a very there's no mistake in this guy he
a very interesting not that one either I
sleep on the sof you sleep in the bed
you want me a woman let's go get mad why
would the Holy Ghost do to all them boy
they was right no good you know God
called them some of my
CH he
the doing the blues dud yeah that's what
I was saying he's doing some kind of
musical number
yeah he's keeping the beat yeah that's
the beat man I mean that's cool it's
definitely
Innovative but I could see like if
you're in like a jazz quartet and you're
feeling it you're the the beat is like
you know sometimes it just fills your
body you feel
anticipation he be like super useful in
a college Acappella group I imagine he
could hit all the weird sounds
yeah you die he was everything but the
homosexual and God you him I know you
done wrong but that's all you cheat you
done
wrong you you D but if you Pap speak in
Tong the Holy Ghost going to clear your
name good breathing techniques goodthing
going clear your name when you come back
when you come back put up your tent on
John do Street put it up in the mid of
the city John do City you knowbody no
good boy you go there I got to say
improvisational skill is pretty
impressive he doesn't never slow down or
M it's just going Tempo yeah it's like a
metronome yeah he is wow yeah that's a
consistent man I would love a if anyone
out there wants has nothing to do this
weekend uh a transcript of
this you get your beaten throw some on
say in the name of Jesus you going to
beat you call H P them on him you going
to beat you got power when you tell me
they
going you get power when you tell me you
going to preach in the name of Jesus
woman woman mother knock on your son
wait hold on he's he's doing something
he's eating right now yeah it kind of
works yeah now is it possible it's
involuntary the sound no no watch very
intentional he's on be yeah he doing
Jazz okay yeah oh Jes I am kind of
curious if he has normal videos yeah
I've watched other videos from where
he's just he's still rambling but not
like that does he seem like a normal
dude no no
no right he's a special dude special guy
uh yeah the the Lord chose him he's
magnetic yeah he's rectangular magnetic
Hallelujah all right so um
oh God this is the other thing all right
do you guys want to figure out lunch
before we get into like the main segment
or should we just we we had figured out
lunch what and then y'all threw a monkey
wrench into the whole work here how are
you going to eat there then oh I wasn't
going to eat but oh well then that then
sure it works for
you come with that heat it's like just
a let me look at well then what you want
what you want know what I want that's
the hardest question in life what about
Middle Eastern would you do
that sure imagine being married to her
and in all the best ways possible in all
the greatest ways possible oh my God I
have actually been so easy with food I
in the all the ways that are wonderful
Imagine The Joy imag the
thrill can you um please condemn what
you just said I what I didn't finish
what I was saying I said imagine being
married to her imagine you know the
privilege
Jo of wow I mean thank you wow love you
so
much incredible what if I mean
really I guess clap those cheeks yeah
it's all it is all me I was trying to
hit a clapping sound effects Sor Ian
wrong WR clap clap but I do I do kind of
think that you need to pitch the spot if
you know what I mean
well give give him some leads I don't
know I don't know we'll be stuck here
forever I'd rather just focus on the
show it's true it's already 3:30 I'm not
we got we got poems to get to we had
Sniper Wolf yeah lot big stuff I can
just figure it out after the show okay
so we won't get you'll skip yeah we'll
skip
copy okay so let's go ahead then and
move on to
um what you want to do a really magical
beautiful moment where we about to do
the Poetry game I'm actually going to go
to the bathroom real fast okay then I'll
come back sounds good I can catch up on
all these lovely super chats hey hit me
with some uh hit me with some lowkey
kind of Jazzy
Vibes drop the heat DJ here it comes I'm
ready I'm ready you're also muted if
you're me okay yeah make sure you're
ready you're ready I'm so ready I've
never been more ready in my
life the we music I this might be
copyright
dude try
again what ah there it is I got it I got
it I got it I got it please hold and
holding okay and here we go the old
timing music no oh oh they just did
everything can we get hold music while
you find that song Maybe oh yeah hold
music for the whole music H how does
this one why does it play all of them I
don't understand what are you doing
listen to everything hold on please hold
and here we go here it
is why is it so uh it's playing
incredibly
low there you go okay not exactly what I
meant but uh you can lower just a hair
from there more of a bed too high too
low I'm trying here yeah yeah I got
you anyways uh I'm trying to find some
of these bigger ones I was seeing
earlier uh
$100 uh High three and the 31st is me
and my hub's uh anniversary oh the 31st
like of this month you guys got married
on Halloween happy anniversary happy
moving around uh is was always home for
us so like clockwork he will come home
from work and we'll watch today's
podcast and I want you freak him out by
yall wishing uh Seth a happy anniversary
for me Seth happy anniversary my friend
Happy Anniversary Seth happy anniversary
happy Halloween to many to many more is
so
hectic uh I see people donate I saw some
super chats you're lost Dan I think this
was people yelling at me when I was
standing up for the no pre-rinsing thing
listen I knew I knew I was going to get
a lot of hate but you
know they hated what Jesus had to say
too let's let me remind
you uh I got it question for Tom okay
it's a little too
late you got that back there uh what do
you
need I'm I'm I'm exploring this
exploring all right
uh you want me to tell someone [__] you
I'll do it who how old are they no no I
don't want you to do that I want you to
play a little bit of music I'm I'm play
the fog horn dude [__] sorry I wasn't
paying attention yeah me neither see it
happens one
sec
[Music]
yeah this is [__] sick feel like I'm
at weekend
birthday I don't it says no copyright
but we never know with these things
that's the thing let's switch it up what
do you say
Dan yeah yeah I know how do you know was
copyright it say it says no copyright
which you never know but I think Dan's
trying to bring down the episode I'm I'm
doing my best out here um do we have the
Sniper Wolf apology in the dock she she
yes we do drop we do so that's pretty
exciting all right guys we are here to
celebrate the Artistry of the H3 podcast
crew this is a story this is a show
about art this is all about free
expression in a in a free in a free
country in a free world a liberal
Society a market place of ideas it's
it's the whole Market Place of creative
ideas and so basically what we're doing
is everybody every one of you has
written a PO
about me mhm are they declarations are
they could it be about anything or is it
love based admiration based uh Ian said
to express ourselves however we wanted
to okay okay that'll okay that's good to
know amazing and um it had it to be a
maximum of 14 lines which is The
Shakespearean Sonet is 14
lines
uh now I don't know if you guys know
this but the rules of a Sonet I'll just
read to you guys
is a Sonet same thing as the poem it's a
type of poem it has 14 lines that
reflects upon a single issue okay it has
to take it usually takes a turn called a
Volta and about eight lines in and then
it resolves the issue by the end sonets
use the iambic
pentameter which is an AB b a b c d CDE
e f e fgg rhyme scheme so
true there's also did anybody follow uh
before we go on too much more about the
theet structure did anybody write AET I
didn't write I like Loosely maybe was
like oh this like looks kind of like a
Sonic but no I did not I would not set
the expectation that high either I
didn't do scan do any of that way the
Amic pentameter is one of the weirdest
[__] things ever I remember that yeah
it's like literally when you perform it
to and you have to do it in I Amic
pentameter it's horrible there's no no
way those dudes wrote in I Amic pamer
the whole goddamn thing Shakespeare was
amazing he was the pioneer of okay fine
he did it so what it mean I am we're
talking Shakespeare Place let's see
um basically d d d when I do count the
CL it's supposed it's like a the the
emphasis on the syllables are supposed
to alternate so it's written in a way
that it's very kind of like kind of sing
songy when you uh do it oh says the term
describes the Rhythm or meter
established by the word in that line
Rhythm it's measuring small groups of
syllables called feet I Amic refers to
the type of foot used here the I am
which in English indicates unstressed
syllables followed by a stress syllable
pentameter indicates a line of five feet
it's [__] nuts it's making me
stressed so anyway I expect iambic
pentameter perfectly
executed and with that being said let's
let's get it started okay
okay you have a little costume over
there if you could go throw that on
quick we got a
costume don't to me
baby all right dead air dead air come
back to the mic all right here's my
Ethan is changing oh we got a background
gorgeous gorgeous wow the Globe Theater
it's great wait we have Shakespearean
music where's that up th this this is it
I can't hear it a little quiet
okay you know what I'm missing Dan it's
one of those more of a music box kind of
thing
like you know what I
mean uh well maybe AB can uh find some I
I just grabbed this one song yeah on how
that uh I'm typing in high te you know
what I mean it's like high tea with the
yeah okay like um yeah like Game of
Thrones
intro what the is this that's the sleeve
what I got it's the sleeve turn it your
arm goes through make sure is Realty
free it's on epidemic let's go your arm
goes through the pillow uh Rings it's
like shoulder pads in World of Warcraft
yeah pretty epic actually plus five
Charisma yeah I like the um
so it's so like I'm
wearing that's a large collar dude the
statement piece for sure that's a nice
piece oh yeah and then these are pants
pantaloons
okay that's better it's viby not exactly
what I had in mind what is
good cool oh I like it
wow yes did they did they expose their
ankles like this like cute little they
wore socks they what socks okay so their
their little ankles weren't exposed that
was [__] Behavior proba sure I don't
give a [__] you can see the shape of
cover
youself all
right
moralists retrieve the poens oo this is
a nice
thick oh yeah pamphlet of poetry right
here
absolutely here we go guys is this one
person or all of them so it's all of
them okay and then I'll guess one yeah
you guys can discuss amongst
[Music]
yourselves all right here we go number
one we got to change the music I'm not
feeling
it it's got to be like God I wish I I
knew what it was that was in my
mind um Zach reads my mind he would know
exactly what I was thinking can you sing
it
again it's like English High te it's
like a music box it's like a almost like
a what does that sound like an accordion
or not an is this
it no I
would
great type hi te
music High te music royalty
free that one something like that I like
what you do I like what you did with
like royal
royal yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's back there like some
classic strings classic strings
something like that brid are we look
someone look in or we okay okay thank
you all right I'll start number
one g g father it's called I don't know
what Gat is gat
Gat what Gat father how is it spelled g
y a t t Gat Gat g g Gat father what is
gat we can talk about it okay we'll talk
so this is oliv no we don't know okay
there once was a man who had great Gat
but lost so much weight and now he does
not once voluptuous and thick his foa a
work of art now the only thing
voluptuous is his big ass
heart nice okay he is a perfect leader
though I do have one gripe please stop
putting paper towels down our toilet
pipes for our poor sweet toilet he loves
to clog and when we need to poop that's
not very POG
wow so I don't know what Gat is gat
what's G yeah that was really good by
the way that was beautiful yeah
beautiful
beautiful somebody tell me what's G I'm
trying to Google it it's it's like aump
dumpy you care what yeah it's a bot
dumpy it's like godamn damn how do you
all know
that rap music people on Twitch say oh a
gat damn look at that g you could say
I've never heard that Google says it
means get your act together
there so there was once a man who had
great Gat but lost so much weight and
now he does
not it's
giving this is giving I'll just say for
now I'll put this on
Ian okay but we can I'll move in mix and
match okay all right I'm taking this
down by the way so we can we can review
later uh the next one is yiro Taco
Bell okay which is already giving me
Clues on today's podcast a topic so
swell we dived deep into the world of
yero Taco
Bell crunchy Delights wrapped up so well
are Tales of tacos made listeners
gel late night F or midday breaks true
there's something for everyone that much
we knew when you're thinking of a meal
that's due buy Taco Bell for the whole
gone darn crew somebody's trying to play
me you're saying uh you think that
that's loves yeah okay otherwise it's
just a cruel prank all right all
right it was very love coded I'll give
you
that thank you guys this is all very
very touching Al this one wasn't about
me it was just kind of about wanting you
to order Taco Bell
you did not follow instructions supposed
to be about
me
uncompromised oh that's so true isn't it
about me
wow oh wapon my
wapon authentic a word worn by few he's
himself through and through outspoken
battling for what's right in dark times
he serves to many as the light words are
his power and he never backs down from a
fight wow this is some hard
sing I can see this clip going around
people being like dude look at what his
crew [__] wrote about
it how embarrassing is
he uh for him we see a rare compilation
a virtues love and honest
Foundation a beacon a rock in this
generation wow more than just the
comedian who made Vape Nation oh wow I
am so much more thank you for so here's
de Ethan with a heart so Grand in our
Memories Forever you'll
stand I'm not
dead only 38 not as a leader but a warm
guiding hand in life's Symphony you're
the best in the band oh wow I would say
I would
say if I didn't know it was written by
one of you guys i' say it was written by
my
mom so that one is uh obviously uh
gushing yeah MH I'm going
to I'm gonna say AB because I mean is it
AB cuz he's an
idiot I think it's AB just cuz obviously
he is kind of known as the simp in a
sense now you do know um I'll just throw
out there and I'm not trying to push you
in any One Direction but that uh Zach
submitted one as well even though he's
not here today he did okay okay I didn't
know that right okay this this might be
a Zach one too but I'll put it on AB for
now okay all right I got it down for ab
uncompromised the heavy simp one
uncompromised also chat is recommending
you do it in a British accent maybe I'll
try give you the Zing that you're
looking
for I mean I would if I could but I'll
try Ethan [__] rules is that the
title yeah Ethan [__] rules okay
called Ethan [__]
Rose from out of the depths of YouTube
Strife emerged a voice a comedic Beacon
of light I can't do it feel embarrassed
that's okay you can stop what if it's a
more of like the peeky blinders uh we
are getting from the depths of YouTube
swife now see I'm not good I just sound
like an
idiot I can't do it just be Queen
Elizabeth can we get a AI uh voice
changer seen that right okay from the
depths of YouTube Strife emerged a voice
a comedic Beacon of light Ethan Klein
with Goofs and gaffs called out
pranksters and brought us laughs oh
that's nice Ian when controversies rage
and a joke over played Ethan Stands
Strong and resilient like freshly mind
Chinese jade
oh Fearless in the face of online
tension Ethan's humor and wit will
always have our attention Ethan [__]
rules powerful oh wait there's more
there's another verse uh now with the H3
podcast he takes the stage engaging in
discussion a digital sage in spite of
the venomous lies Fallen fans develop
wow Ethan great moves keep it
[Music]
up I'll put that one on Zach just
because of the Ethan [__] rules I
feel like that does feel like a Zach
title
true but um I should say too none of us
have heard each others we all submitted
it to uh to Ian uh coordinate so we only
know our own oh that's exciting
yeah all right the next one is called
the bird and the
cricket bird wow Cricket I I get the
sense there's going to be a lesson in
here
journey in the boundless void a wind is
whipping un tamed uncaged bird Spirit
unnamed each quip each gesture Testament
to Freedom's pull clouds endlessly
gather beguiled by the
boundlessness for him boundaries are an
illusion mere smoke and air branches
Creek and strain upon will so
fair adits his dance admit Amit amidst
his dance
the cricet stands watchful still
Shepherd admidst the grass bending with
its will tending his crops seeking
Harmony within the
vast in this unseeable inpl our nature
entwined one's endless Horizon met by
the Stillness of
mine it's not that bad someone try to
[__]
me adid the Whirlwind a silent spell is
cast
wow I
am the bird in the
cricket so clearly the bird is eats
crickets
right so does somebody feel that I'm
eating
them or am I the cricket are you eating
me are you the cricket what's going
on if you want cam if you wanted lunch
you could just
ask thank you Bab baby I love you
actually I have no idea I'll put it on
camera just cuz Okay he likes food and
it's about and bird eating something
there is a bird in it there a bird on
cam always
true next one's called Ethan
Ethan it's just called Ethan it's called
Ethan comma Ethan oh double Ethan okay
Ethan Klein is the name and one you
won't forget he speaks his true mind you
have to admit with humor wit and Grace
he brings laughter to the internet's
Embrace he clogs toilets with no
fear a SK a skill few dare to boast but
he's
sincere excuse
me in shorts and slippers Life's a comfy
chair with K zero in hand he is the king
here though once he smoked crack a tail
bizaar he's bounced back stronger and
wiser than before Beacon of laughter is
shining like a star in the world of
content he'll always soar Ethan a
character so unique in Goofs and gas
he'll cheer up your
[Laughter]
week thank
you thank
you Ethan Ethan Ethan o
[Music]
Ethan not o just Ethan Ethan oh mm Ethan
Klein I feel like maybe this one I don't
know why see I I I just I'm feeling aen
on this
one potentially I don't know I don't
there's an earnestness to it I don't
know yeah Lena has got the [__] locked
down this one's called cold mountains
wow cold mountains wh yo this one is
like this one's pretty rhythmed out got
do we have a genuine Sonet on our hands
M 14 lines M the sentences are long yeah
the sonnet lines are pretty long oh okay
there's also supposed to be an exact
amount of syllables in each line too oh
my God all right here we go cold
mountains hark ye fiery Wells erupting
churning depths render bad luck cold is
the knife of
indigestion agitating a rash of coarse
skin a dash of speed seeks soless on the
bull he is stuck absorbing the words of
the world scrolling above
porcelain H the Chimes of obligation
rings deafened at top cold
mountains broken doors belly steadfast
locks refusing external
drones lost in ye flushing
trials a day floweth ethereal fountains
lightning strikes Disturbed Eden wal
betwix Orange
cones the whispering
Woodsman FS the sinking Marsh
logs serpents minations seek to damn thy
floods mhm silence ye that
bowels tide break beneath thy full moon
or Darkness Shipwrecked clogs glowing
firm firmament hearken Fallen Doom
descend ye pap bird
towels Cold Mountain wow probably well I
really like that on it's not down it's
not oh on Wing a light from shared
quarters thy cold mountains
shaketh wise orders and masks of ashamed
Glee a bridge collapsed in his
wake call you fat I don't know but I do
know I would maybe call this hot
mountains if it was I wrot Mounds it's
like a Romeo
Julia okay well uh give it up for that
one yeah that was that was nice oh what
I mean I've never
uh I've never read a poem dedicated to
[__] but this is pretty good one this is
one of the
best cold mountains it sounds like a
Academy award-winning movie M I think it
was what's your instinct tell you what
about the movie no about this who wrote
this one oh
right cold mountains somebody here
is really getting into the literature
the the writing aspect of it
m also passionate about my dumps so like
there's a there's a crossover there hey
man hary fairy Wells fiery Wells erupt
churning depths render bad luck cold is
the the knife of indigestion agitation a
rash of coarse
skin I'm sorry what was
that
H who would get so into the writing I'm
thinking it could be
Olivia I'm thinking it could be Sam
perhaps I've been listening to Olivia
the entire
time I'll put this I'll put this one on
Olivia for now Olivia yeah
okay next one is called he comes from
comes from you want to come he comes
from from everywhere he comes from Donna
and Gary Klein I'm GNA come Santa
Barbara and crack smoked only one time
hold on I'm not from Santa
Barbara just say I'm sorry somebody who
knows you really well yeah wait it is
called he comes from he comes from this
kind of the center piece of the whole
thing says I'm from Santa Barbara which
is really it's not really even well
you're from Ventura which is about what
40 minutes away from
but further an hour
maybe okay edits can be made post all
right so I'm from S I wish I was from
Santa barar That's a way nicer city
than he comes from da and Gary Klein
Santa Barbara and smoked crack only one
time he comes from an avoidance of
youth's evidential fleet Fleet though
with Reckless abandon an eternal child's
heartbeat huh rage rage against the
dying of it Ethan Klein YouTube's Young
Prince yet to kick the bucket thank
you he comes from a
toe acting as if the only life force of
a levitated slide before it's peeling
comes from a toe say that again acting
as the only life force of a levitated
slide before its peeling just saying and
Chestnut causing an allergic reaction to
the
feeling he is from Ela and Teddy and
Bruce and of all the words and phrases
he'll continue to
misuse
hm okay so so so
somebody somebody I'm thinking who of
you would think I lived in Santa Barbara
it would have to be somebody
who why would you think
that somebody who doesn't somebody who's
not from here not familiar with the
SoCal not a native of of La for sure so
which would exclude quite a few of you
guys frankly
sure dude uh Olivia
Z that it everybody else is somewhere
else three of us I'm feeling it that
it's love and even though he is the
simp I feel like the Santa Barbara thing
is a mistake that I can see him making
because he's new here he doesn't know
the difference okay now I will point out
that you have already signed love to the
uh the Taco Bell one oh [__] I take it
back not love that one's definitely love
okay who did this who did this could
this one could be Sam because she
doesn't know about like do you know
about cities and stuff Sam I know you
don't know faces do you know the
difference between cities I know cities
okay I don't know faces mail for
Sam ah Santa
Barbara she it could have been just a
mistake like no you are like you went to
school in Santa Cruz maybe it was just I
have no association with Santa Barbara
right Santa how many who's left cam Dan
uh you have assigned cam you haven't
assigned me you haven't assigned
uh um no you did assign it Lena is it
just you have done Lena I did yeah
Lena's here who am I Sam myself and oh
Ian Ian no wait the first one gave so
wait these are the last two three four
oh no no there's not there's three more
I can't including this no there's two
more this is it this is the last two my
bad so it's just Dan and
cam Dan so I'm gonna put this
one no you do have one assigned toam is
not from here yeah I think I'm going to
put he comes from to cam I mean listen
we know he he loves Boston you when it
comes to that area he's got it all
unlock SoCal he's still working on it
cam is my favorite Bunny Man uh I will
point out that you assigned the bird in
the cricket to cam [__] then who didn't
I so who is Miss yeah it was me and it's
Sam and I think just those two I think
it's just me and Sam okay okay then Sam
gets the heat comes from okay Dan Dan
being a Los Angeles native mhm so
there's just one more you say one more
this is obviously Dan yep assuming you
got them all right one of a kind One of
a Kind come hither come quick it's like
I don't know and if you're good I'll
show you a trick listen to my tale about
a host a boss
and allaround
mench open toe shoes with socks that may
give a kick the ultimate Alpha without a
stitch stitch stitch oh yes a stitch of
cloth all year round his Teddy fresh
drip it's a shame I cannot relay on the
open air for I am in a far away
place let the man speak not in a Boby
type of way
but hear his wise words so cheers to my
dude Ethan one of a kind and make sure
to flush this one is definitely Zach
just because so many sound references Z
I feel like the tell who else uses the
word
mench was a giveaway too yeah so the one
that you had given to Zach was Ethan
[__] rules okay so that one so one of
a kind I'm putting on Zach then Ethan
[__] rulle so that only leaves me do
you think that I wrote Ethan [__]
rules
no
no absolutely not got him interesting
but he says that every day yeah as soon
as I come in I mean it's it's required
it's the password to get in the building
[__] so we all say that though oh yeah
everyone kisses the ring before the show
starts
um dude I got I don't know Ethan [__]
rules hear it again should we hear it
you sons of [__] I like you you can't
rule me out I'm K I'm kid from out of
the depths of YouTube Strife emerged a
voice a comedic Beacon of life than
Ethan Klein with Goofs and gaffs called
out pranksters and Broad us laughs an OG
fan mhm it's a prank
bro uh when controversy raged and a
joke's overplayed Ethan Stands Strong
and resilient like freshly mint freshly
mind Chinese Jade Fearless in the face
of online tension Ethan Tor and Wht will
always have our attention old school
into the Jade thing I do think that Dan
does fit some of that requirements
actually cuz Dan does know a lot of the
old lore mhm and I do love Jade I'm not
going to deny that I I'll put it on Dan
maybe he is Ethan [__] rules
huh who knows all right let me change
this thing's hot and I'll leave it on
I'll leave it on leave it on Jack you
look great give it up well done on the
reading
nice
okay how long we've been going Dan uh
we've been going uh 2 hours 30 minutes
and 54 seconds actually thanks for
asking
a what all
right so at the top we have yet
impressed with this pretty pretty fluffy
yeah I like The Vibes me too you know
okay so here I can uh think keep pull
this up real
quick so get
father um has been fantastic was the one
that said that I was G but I lost weight
and no I'm not gat you don't have the
gat you don't have a gat anymore I said
this one was Ian who wrote Gat
father that was mine oh I thought it
to be honest Sam would
say cuz you know all that [__] you're
you're like that you told us about chugi
sticking out your G for the
rler all right so the the first the
guess was Ian the result was Sam which
obviously is going to make this one
incorrect as well but we'll we'll Circle
back I love it I guess you were close
were technically close yeah they spend a
lot of time ask you this samed did Ian
look at this at all no he did not he
didn't even see it no
input all right the yera Taco Bell one
which I said we love obviously an Ode to
Taco
Bell that we know more than an OED to
Taco Bell than it was to you I don't
think I was even mentioned frankly I
don't know I heard make a make one for
youing to it that's the thing and that
that's what the major is too it's like
rules are meant to be broken dude hell
yeah bro like you don't have to really
even write about my promp you got me
yeah so this is you yeah and chat
gbt who else you wait hold on yeah who
else how many people use chat gbt I did
not I did not cuz I mean it's a good ide
I mean hell it's one way to do yeah
honestly English language like I feel
like I would have had no chance writing
like you guys so I probably would have
had to do that too I probably would have
been ble to do it in Swedish either but
I was this felt like a school task and I
wanted it over as fast as possible but
you punched it up with your own touch
too right yeah I did personalize it a
lot so what was your prompt to Chad gbt
yeah what' you ask I'd make um make a
poem convincing my boss to buy Taco
bomb okay oh hell yeah brother all right
next is
uncompromised this one is the one that
was like heavy s yeah this was Heavy
sing going on in this one and you said
AB uncompromised oh wapon my wapon
authentic a word warn by few he's
himself through and
through so here's de Ethan with a heart
so Grand yeah I thought it was
AB who else would gush over me like that
Zach maybe but I don't think I think we
know
Zach's Olivia maybe I don't know let's
he who did it I hope this doesn't make
you sound like a douche come forward it
was me it was baby of course it was
there was a little mistake that cap Oh
Captain My Captain that was the original
title and I maybe I was misleading when
I sent it to Ian but yeah that that
Line's not supposed to be in there that
was that was the first title wait which
Line's not supposed to be here uh well
captain my captain Oh WAP my WAP oh
that's supposed to be the title yeah
well and then I changed it I changed it
and then okay there's a lot of there's a
lot of drafts yeah I got the spirit of
it yeah and thank you AB yeah yeah it's
very
touching a truly a wonderful uh
Testament to your love for me initially
I wanted to send the uh Speech from Meet
the
Parents and I Dan said I couldn't do
that it's cheating so I said okay right
I just love the the idea of you reading
the lines you gave me life you gave me
milk you want me to read it no it's all
good I don't know your speech from Meet
the [__] [__] Meet the
Parents the first one Meet the Parents
and it gets a little dark I mean you
gave me life you gave me milk you gave
me courage your name was Angela Angela
but it say your name was Ethan yeah just
swap it up for Ethan right the angel
from heaven but well the the Angela part
is kind but you are also an angel of God
and he needed you too selfishly I tried
to keep you here while the cancer ate
away your
organ like an Unstoppable Rebel Force
but I couldn't save you I and I shall
you see it was a good idea Dan we the
beginning was good it's what happened in
that scene did he laugh or something he
no he he almost knocked over the ear or
he was talking about the room that his
mother was in and then his wife
encouraged him to read I got to say I
saw that with my family when I was a kid
man that movie is [__]
funny good [__] I told AB it' be really
great to use that I was cracking up and
it got kind morbid with the cancer stuff
and he's like oh I can just switch it
with
loopus that's smart true but Dan is true
in the sense
that how am I ever going to guess it's
you cuz it's so Random you don't
understand me so there you're just so
Random yeah so Random so random dude so
random thank you ab and there you go I'm
two for three and I liked it to even
take credit for the Gat
one uh it's not your fault Sam and Ian
are different people well that's your
opinion all right this one is a really
mysterious one [__] rules that title
really throws it off I don't know
another like pretty hard sing
one Ethan [__] rules from out the
depths of YouTube Strife emerged a voice
a comedic Beacon of
life we wrote Dan Dan Dan and again this
is I don't have high confidence in this
but the reason I did I think Dan might
work is because of
the the old school knowledge as well as
the uh knowing you're not from Santa
Barbara yeah can I say something before
you guys this one gave me real chat GPT
Vibes and I want to say that before he
gets who it is I want to call anyone out
but I don't know I going chat GPT or
maybe someone just a great writer I
don't know well let's see that was me
and [__] you
AB I can see that actually so this GPT
cam no no I could see being cam then
you're a great writer yeah thank you I'm
not I mean I'm not great but come
[Applause]
onb never interesting so the bird one is
not
cam okay Cam thank you Ethan [__]
rolls thank
you whoa very nice all right so so far
we're two to two for two or two for four
I guess should thank you Cameron so kind
the bird in the Crickets someone got
really poetic with this one
one and okay this one oh see this one I
wrote cam okay yeah mhm in the boundless
void a wind is whipping Untamed uncaged
bird Spirit unnamed each quip each
gesture Testament to Freedom's
pole clouds endlessly gather beguiled by
the boundlessness for him boundaries are
Illusions mere smoke and air branches
Creek and strain upon will so
fair all right who was it come forward
see that one was me you had me and cam
swap I knew it boom boom so what is this
what are you saying Dan uh well uh I
ended up writing it kind of about um my
you're the you're the bird okay I'm the
cricet so I'm eating you it's not about
the eating it's more the cricet he's
down in the grass and he's trying to
make a home and and there's the wind and
the bird the bird is kicking up wind and
rustling him around all the time dude I
told you I don't want to talk about
Israel and Gaza
today admidst its dance the cricet
stands watchful still Shepherds amidst
the grass bending with its will see
shepherding you
along the cricket I'm shepher the bird
okay tending his crops seeking Harmony
within the
vast and this unseeable interplay our
nature entwined one's endless Horizon
met by the still of mine oh yeah then
you this is not romantic line right it's
not romantic things aren't that [__]
deep about our clashing personality
types but that we make something
beautiful out of it admidst the
Whirlwind a silent spell is cast wow wow
thank you thank you thank
you beautiful how did you become
gang uh this one is Ethan
Ethan who I said Lena did mhm uh this
one was I
think Ethan Klein is the name and one
you won't forget he speaks his true mind
you have to admit it's got a nice
rhyme it hits on a lot of nice points
but the clogging the
toilet oh this was the PO
zero it was it the Cold Mountain that
was really focused on the clogging the
toilet thing yeah okay but also Lena
usually does get me the Coke Zeros
during the show so is this yours Lena it
is nailed it I'm so happy you knew wow
got another one all right PR
good wow I feel so
uh I feel so insightful for that you are
you are that's true thank you Lena with
Coke Zero in
hand he smoked crack
once it's true thank you thank you true
now cold mountains this one is going to
be this one's got to be Ian
so you put Olivia we don't need to
switch it cuz whatever but this one's e
but you still haven't um it could still
be Olivia yeah I don't think it is
though okay harky fiery Wells erupting
churning depths render bad who would
like obsess over my mountain of [__]
like this you all look
gay it's got to be Ian Ian did you write
this I did write that one yes yes of
course that one was
Ian cold mountains such a heartfelt
poetic I love very evocative uh uh
imagery that he pulled out disgusting
yeah very beautiful y yeah I just the
Revelation I just kept thinking about it
and then there's a detail that people
don't know for the subathon you were
like let's let's break another door and
knowing that you were playing fast and
loose this way we would have had no
toilet and I I just have been thinking
about that Die Hard energy you've been
living
with it it caused some poetic stir yeah
it stirred something in him and the Cold
Mountain is just my my [__] sitting I I
sort of imagine you as this great
philosopher king on the toilet this big
mountain and we're trying to we can't
call up to you to come back cuz you just
go in there for a while
andan the really [__] things up so I'm
up on the Cold Mountain yes right cuz I
said well warm Mountain cuz I thought it
was a reference to my Mounds yeah it
more but it could be it could be both
temperatures yeah right I I wrote that I
was out of town the last two days for a
family thing and uh I wrote that on the
plane and I think the person next to me
kept reading my screen and I was just
writing this poem about
[__] I hope they enjoyed that you
did take you a while Ian it it filled up
the flight I was just thinking of this
definitely
some beautiful words here thank you
thank HED upon my soul
serpents minations seek to damn thy
floods silence ye
bowels tide break beneath thy full moon
o or darken shipwreck
clogs glowing firmament hearken falling
Doom descend ye paper
towels descend like descending into the
depths of Hell okay uh he comes from
this is the one this is the Santa
Barbara one what was the Santa Barbara
one
not Sam and yeah Sam's been accounted
for so it uh there's only a few options
left who's left um Z Zack
Olivia and Olivia Poss to be was the LA
natives oh so then I think this one's
Olivia a good point you're right I just
wrote the wrong Santa and then before we
started I asked Ian if I could change it
and he was like nope you've locked in
already and I was like [__] but that
that makes sense because again Zach is a
la native so is Olivia she is too oh you
are oh yeah you were in college
somewhere else and what the hell I know
I just wrote the wrong Santa when I
wrote it down but I'm not she me Santa
Cruz but's not fromant Santa Claus Santa
Claus yeah he comes from Dan Donna and
Gary Klein Santa Claus yep that Santa
Claus and cracks smoked only one time
[__] baby I meant Santa Cruz oh Santa
Cruz
yes [__] baby [__] you I didn't
understand I was trying to work it out I
did not mean Santa Claus that didn't
make a lot of sense so that's twice that
you've thrown out the wrong Santa yes um
so that only leaves Zach for the last
one which uh I think no I'm doing pretty
good here yeah so
uh so that means that you got that one
right so that that's it that's the run
too is that right bad [__] dang I think
I did pretty good you did pretty good
considering you got four of them right
out of out of what eight or nine oh hold
on I got Love's right I got ab's right I
got Lena's right and I got Zach and
Olivia that's five yeah right you didn't
get Zach and Olivia you would guess this
one was Sam
okay oh my God someone in chat just
reminded me something Colleen is from
Santa Barbara oh
subliminal yeah she is such Santa
Barbara Santa Barbara I would never coin
you as Santa Barbara don't worry never
again
it's a lot richer than
vura very good that was fun cheero chip
chip
Cheerio thank you guys everybody
somebody said all these were so chat gbt
coded it look at what chat gbt is doing
to us as a society look at the
screenshot I now you can't even like
believe that anything's real first of
all I th% believe that uh they wrote
this because I mean chat should be let's
right can you write a poem with Max 14
lines theet right now my boss Ethan
Klein the host of the H3 podcast things
to
include things to include he smoked
crack once uhhuh he's from Santa
Cruz or he he went he went he went to
school in Santa Cruz mhm uh he he clogs
toilets he clogs toilets with paper
towels with paper towels and poop right
and uh anything
else uh yeah he hosts a show and he has
a controversial show ugly you are
disgusting all right let's see in the
heart of podcast where controversy lies
Ethan Clan St Ethan Klein Stands Tall
with a glint in his eyes one smoked
crack a misstep in his of his youth yet
he's come so far to speak his own truth
Santa Cruz schooled him by the ocean's
Embrace a journey of knowledge a
spirited Chase yet admits Tales profound
one fact does swoop he's notorious for
clogging with paper and
poop it's Prett good it's pretty good
that's that's my point is like when
chachu does it it's
like too
clean there's more h3's host with a show
that can RI challenging Norms with a
style so
vile
chill but admidst the debate and the
laughter he SWS Ethan remains a legend
as the podcast world knows oh thank you
okay very nice I think that's the thing
uh uh too is like um did you even ask it
to rhyme no yeah it right and it was
just coming up with all those rhy like I
was having a hell of a time making it
rhyme which is why I didn't end up doing
the sauna thing and I was like [__] it
poems don't need to rhyme right no and
it was used in a book do you use like a
there's like a
rhyme Finder right rhymer.com I did look
that up for one because I really
couldn't think of anything and I looked
through the list of rhyming words and
help I'm bust it I asked shot gbt to
make it worse I I wrote like make it
amateur mhm make it sound like I don't
know what I'm doing cuz I was thinking
that one was not as clean as yeah yeah
chat gbt would have made it and I
changed wor off too so I made it pretty
original right still we can run them
through chat
gbt detectors too you know should I do
that should I try to expose you guys I
sent a screenshot of mine oh [__] I
don't do that I don't I trust you guys
Cameron's pass the test 0% I will try
mine then I will say I'll try loves list
think of how to dig ourselves out of
this I don't know how reliable these are
but it's total [__] oh really it
really is from what use AI to cat the AI
That's not fraud there might be tools
that are good at it but not these free
ones no I think it yeah exact right yeah
cuz I know universities and stuff has
pretty Advanced ones they probably have
ones that yeah maybe way better yeah
that being
said I'm going to run I'm going to run
mine through there and see what it says
uh how how long we've been going Dan
hours 50 minutes all right perfect so
I'm going to wait for ELA or well I can
start it now so our M oh okay yeah
sniper never mind the these things are
completely accurate they're completely
trustworthy I just put mine in it says
0% written by a human how can they know
that how can they know 0% I really don't
know can you paste yours that it just
wrote for you so we can test it out was
it worth all the here death oh yeah yeah
here that's a good idea I'll send it to
you in Discord yeah and I'll just copy
it
in
God God here it is oh it says 0% on mine
too [__] that's oh [__] I sent you this
one this one is this one is straight out
of it yeah this is Super Chat GP
Cod another one ahead detect this says
zero zero yeah this is worthless oh
these are [__] wait hold on what
qualifies this thing sucks yeah okay
well
anyways all right let's talk
[Music]
about
we talked previously Sniper Wolf is a
huge reaction Channel Jack's film front
of the show great
guy got into a little bit of a beef with
her which result he was calling her out
for doing really lazy reactions
essentially stealing content from people
not giving them credit not giving them
shout outs just using people mhm and
Jack made a video talking about it which
is fair fair fair and she reacted on
Twitter by name calling him calling him
bald saying all kinds of crazy out of
pocket [__] so I think that's what
partially motivated Jack's films to
creating his now
notorious and very successful I'll say J
Jack's films that's true which I'll pull
up for you Jack this is um
essentially right he does reactions to
sniper Wolf's
reactions wait did he erase it is that
what
happened uh let me check I don't see it
I think YouTu made him erase it no
really they [__] made him erase it
dude that's
crazy I knew they were going to say he
was harassing her I just knew it wait no
I see it oh [__] up I typed JJ Jack
films
did you do three JS I did four oh
there's your problem okay my bad back it
all up button button but but also how
bad is YouTube search if it's just one
off mean you know what I mean it's a big
channel it's got half a million Subs
that's so useless what the [__] so he
hasn't posted one in seven days which is
a shame cuz these are regularly getting
half a million views per and they're all
just reactions to her reactions right
and frankly there's always done X bingo
in a while here's how frankly oh dude ad
oh it's happening dude it's happening
wait hold on I just exit out and then
continue though so what from what I
understand and this was just something I
read online so I don't know if they're
going to roll it out this way they're
this is their way of easing you into it
eventually you won't be able to dismiss
that window you'll have to turn off the
app I wonder if I'm going to make more
money for sure if I won't even notice uh
I guess it would be interesting to see
if it is actually effective I mean
twitch did it a couple years ago and
it's pretty [__] effective you can't
really skip the ads on Twitch T it's
like hardcoded in yeah that's it's going
as I understand the reason that YouTube
didn't do this earlier is because they
were already filling all the inventory
that they
sold they didn't really even need it and
frankly the people who are doing Adblock
are probably more Savvy and less prone
to C looking ads anyway yeah sure but
now I'm assuming they have more capacity
and so that that that might be why well
we'll see uh anyway I'll get premium on
that account that you use so we can yes
yeah we're PR we're pred
up Chad saying clear your cash to avoid
that uh don't do that though because
it'll log us
out oh alt f4 what's next chat nothing
so yeah he made these videos uh reacting
to her reactions quite clever actually
and actually quite transformative yeah a
really interesting way to make an
actually transformative video and he
also continues to bring up really
interesting weird things she does like
inserting the same exact reaction
inserting the same video more than one
time and all kinds of just really lazy
blatant weird kind of [__] that goes on
in her content
Factory well this all heated up when
um let's see she went to his
house and took a picture of his
house just a picture of his house yeah
and posted it to social
media Jack's editor
here oh what's up thanks for covering
means a lot the people are talking about
this uh thank you CUO C CUO yya okay we
love we love Jack's editor
shout out shout out yes so she went to
his house do we have the let me pull up
the uh she pulled up to his house took a
photo of the front then showed the front
very obviously and the address I think
and posted it which is
insane so insane and for another Creator
to do that to another Creator like a big
established Creator this she gets like
100 million views she's oted by YouTube
She's endorsed by YouTube yeah she's
featured speaker at VidCon they're
retweeting her videos from the official
YouTube account so that's why the whole
thing started right because she was a a
speaker at a YouTube event yeah right
you're right Jack was like why are you
promoting this content Thief as someone
to like look up to for for future
creators and he's got a really good
point definitely fair
I think his point was like you should be
focusing on people that actually are
being creative and using creating new
content uh
so Jack now since that
happened and a lot of people online have
been saying something has to be done
about this you cannot show up to another
Creator's house and just [__] dox
them not only is it potentially illegal
and super [__] up the precedent of
that is insane like YouTube cannot allow
this to go unpunished because like what
is this the new Norm now you just go dox
someone you're beefing with yeah I mean
it's so dangerous like you don't know
what that could lead to but very
dangerous stuff could happen dude it's
such such a violation of privacy man
it's not even
funny but um so going into how this all
went down and the aftermath of all this
YouTube actually tweeted this out which
is kind of a poor timing they said what
did be to meta to do a reaction video to
a reaction
video they tweeted this
out on the 18th two days ago first of
all what a dumb tweet like yeah you're
the first person that ever [__]
thought of that Jack actually made a
joke video about that like 10 years ago
right that this is like 10 years ago
oh come on
YouTube uh he got hit with the community
notes by the way
uh for additional context is it needs to
be known that this tweet was written in
the wake of a controversy regarding a
reaction YouTuber Sniper Wolf who
recently leaked the personal information
of a fellow Creator on the platform Jack
film so that's that is helpful I'll rate
that yeah really cross the line that is
helpful
submit thank
you um so again YouTube just kind of
missing the point
as always Philly D friend of the show
great
guy Fair always coverage always coverage
our stories fairly and
accurately he said of this tweet just a
silly silly fun goof y'all should react
to this video so true so true that
is well tweeted by uh Philip def
Franco prolific hiker mountains
man Cold Mountain hiker
so now but now that people are getting
more and more and more angry people have
started to sift through her old
controversies which often happens when
people you know come under the the
microscope there's some pretty wild
stuff in here I I got to
say um here's an Omegle of her offering
to show an underage boy her boobs if she
if they twerked for
her whoa which is like today's standard
that's
like
crazy do we know what year this is
from guys you you really got me put
showing drama alert all
right the scoop they got the yellow
stack I I I looked for another source uh
but that's wow that's the one shout out
drama alert shout out drama
alert um Sniper Wolf accused of
commercial commercial sexual ual iation
of miners wait what does that mean she
not doing like sex
train I don't what the [__] you don't
have to make it sound worse than it is
it's already pretty bad right what a
[__] in the video she asked youngl
looking individuals to twerk she has
since allegedly privated the video what
do you mean allegedly did she private or
not dummy they don't want to do any
research it's like allegedly I don't
[__] know's I don't know just go look
I have like literally a three man crew
on this stuff yeah I can tell damn so he
says do you think he individual underage
so I suppose the age is unknown but
let's take a look I mean yeah those kids
are definitely under 18 by the look of
it so here's the chat I'll type
it she wrote twerk for
me come on I'll show
tits o
yeah oh those kids are young he's really
young those kids are super young like 14
15 maybe pretty young to me I don't know
don't you just have a seat right over
there please why do you want to see them
twerk I would guess 14 yeah they look
right down there
oh was she a Creator at this time what
is this yeah she's doing like a video a
Meo video was on the and they don't know
they're being recorded either to add to
the right so no uh cookies for
you
[Laughter]
ster I love it big ass she
said yeah let's go come on no come on
let's do
it yeah keemstar blurred it out thank
you keemstar oh yeah that's [__]
awesome yeah let's get the little guy
too I wanted to see the little guy okay
uh-uh don't like the way you said that
yeah no good no boy no no come on both
of you just twerk together do it
together oh I can't see move the camera
what kind of cont is I couldn't
see oh yeah yeah you're really good at
it yeah let me see the other guy do it
yeah see the little
guy oh someone came sh Mom's here oh no
is that is that
mom come on let's go let's go get your
mom in here let it too yeah yeah your
son's doing all this for
tits God the [__] e that's pretty weird
it's pretty just horrible just really
gross like just really bad sense of
uh everything everything
upside down upside down that girl came
from she does seem to be based on her
interactions with Jack and obviously
doxing him on purses a really nasty
person just a mean spirited real
nasty uh you know what I mean but that's
not the only thing that's just one
there's uh three another one here is
she's asking a 16-year-old girl
allegedly 16 to flash
her so what is why are you C oh why oh
yeah this one was really weird I I saw
this one this is just a chat log it's a
picture of this girl says she's 16 and
she's there looking like about to lift
her top it looks like in fact I'd be
wouldn't
be yeah she does it she does do it but
but the thing there's a little bit of A
Wrinkle In This that person in the top
is one of those Bots trying to make
other people do it it's not that girl
how do you
know it makes sense if you watch the
whole video you're alleging that are you
alleging that I guess I'm alleging
that I got you no I mean Yoo I met this
high school girl that I I see what you
mean that that this was like some sex
spot that's like omeg or whatever that
she's interacting with okay well then
that the craziest stories from Omega
people who would like jerk off on there
and then and then they they record it
and blackmail them oh and then the other
thing is they can replace the camera so
this one I heard this one guy was
getting being blackmailed and they said
pay us or we're going to send this to
everyone you
know and they're going to change the
picture of like an adult woman he was
talking with at the time to a child a
young boy oh my God so I think that is
literally like a black male bot yeah so
this might have been one of those I
don't think it was a bot I think they're
real people there's real people shatting
but the video is not the person shatting
so [__] up man that happened to a
friend of mine who was literally the
nicest guy and you know he just I don't
know he's not his luck he hasn't he
hasn't ever dated anyone he fell for
this scam and literally like his parents
called all of us all of his friends and
said like he's on like suicide watch
like we got to keep an eye out on him
because it was so bad they they added
all his parents friends on
Facebook yeah dude it's so so cruel the
thing is like it's gross to I mean the
thing is at the time they're doing it
with another consenting adult they think
they think yeah
yeah was this website like all bad news
I feel like uh back
then it's just it was pretty nuts I
think it's still open but at least they
they have one for like showing dick and
one for not I think like two really
there two tears although we we did a
thing with your mom on omegal uh on
families once do you remember and she
saw dick right that did end up happening
right I feel like that's the only thing
that happens on there pretty much I mean
if you're going there you're expecting
it yeah one way or the other anyway
here's the chat amazing
um hey how are you 16 you nice so the
The Stranger is the girl texting to her
right yeah you see at the top is says
stranger may be using a simulated webcam
I think that's maybe the tell that
there's something fishy going
on uh byy your mic is off cut nice I can
now you're sexy want to show each other
our boobs want me to show you first uh
she said so do you think that this
wasn't this was her just [__] with
the
robot I mean now yeah I mean I thought
it was confirmed but now I don't have
the source to that but I I thought when
I watch it was confirmed okay but I
can't look into fair enough they should
throw her I mean who's the girl some
this is a real girl who's showing her
yeah that's the yeah someone's using her
picture for sure that's I don't know who
that is uh but
okay uh sniper wolves actively deleting
and cating videos off her Channel as
they are
discovered allegedly that's not
surprising I mean you
know C was actively deleting and
cremating videos just forther proving
that every day YouTube doesn't act they
are actively allowing her to erase
evidence from her Channel they are
complicit take down tracker oh my God
girl on Omega taken down ask Wolf new
Cod Nails craziest thing on
Omega it's just
too but um
anyway so uh YouTube finally updated us
they made a statement they
said we are confirming that Sniper Wolf
has received a temporary monetization
suspension per greater responsibility
policies I'm assuming that's probably
like two
weeks something like that what I've seen
maybe even a week I don't know they said
off platform actions that put others
personal safety at
risk uh harm our community and the
behavior on both sides isn't what we
want on YouTube hoping everyone helps
move this convo to a better place they
both sides yeah I did it which is
[__]
lame like one person definitely like
that wasn't necessary I know what
happened though because I've been
through this with keemstar right where
they were like you need to stop making
videos about him is they consider it
bullying you want this Keem because he
he goes to YouTube and [__] and cries
and exaggerates and Hyperbole and gives
him his whole side which he did I don't
know if you guys remember how much he
cried to YouTube that I was bullying him
which is kind of true wait so you're
saying YouTube told you to stop making
videos content nuk but that doesn't make
any sense because you are friends with
the CEO and control YouTube and all you
have to do is make a phone call and get
people banned that's what I've heard
online I can't even get someone to
review one of my podcasts it's been like
seven [__] days there's been a
podcast under review yellow oh wow that
doesn't make sense to me if I can't get
a review then like who
can so FR also I run a business here
yeah seven days anyway yeah so they both
sides it wonderful people on both sides
thank
you which is kind of
[__] I had a feeling they were going
to do that though they were going to
tell them you need to chill on
the on the videos and he did it's been
seven days he hasn't posted which is a
shame because that that channel was
turning into a Dynamo was hitting
getting good good content was good it
was good like that's annoying bro yeah
well well said uh
furthermore Sniper Wolf put out an
apology again I think this was probably
compelled by
YouTube and here's the thing so what I
think happened behind the scenes was
Leah Sniper Wolf was complaining and
crying she has deep connections to
YouTube it seems like or at
least I don't want to say anything mean
for to the people that work there but
she
has people that listen to
her and so she I'm
sure uh allegedly I'm
sure that she's been bitching behind the
scenes Non-Stop about being harassed and
that's probably the first YouTube heard
about this is from her being like I'm
being harassed by this guy she
said
let me start by saying I'm sorry for my
recent actions it's inexcusable dude the
way that she like she was like I don't
care [__] you
yeah yeah you posted your own address
online remember just Google Jack film's
home
address amazing she said I'm sorry to
Jack film YouTube and the entire Creator
Community she's apologizing to us and my
credible fans for not being a better
example for appropriate conflict resolu
wait what my incredible fans are
not she's apologizing to her fans oh oh
oh okay she's sorry to Jack to YouTube
and her incredible fans I'm really Jack
SS well we certainly don't see eye to
eye and have our differences I'm sorry
for reacting the way I did when I should
have taken the opportunity to show young
creators how adults and professionals
resolve Conflict by commuting direct
this was chat gbt written
bro by communicating directly
respectfully and privately not for views
or content but a meaningful example of
how conflict should be resolved what the
[__] is this I will reach out directly
and hope we can find some time to
connect and communicate respectfully I'd
also like to thank YouTube for holding
me
accountable and most of all I want to
thank
YouTube who demonetized me for two weeks
and I'm so glad they did
that I deserved it I deserve it respect
the decision and appropriate appreciate
the opportunity to learn and grow from a
true laps in judgment it's almost
like the fact that she's she's over
owning it she's like over it's it
strikes me as disingenuous just because
it's so over the top right talk about
the allegations but who knows maybe
she's uh genuinely
uh apologetic not much evidence though
to support that other than this
sweet so so actually do we think the
apology is a little too good I [__]
it's too like I I it's like this I come
before you a guilty
person everything you've heard about me
is
true and
worse in YouTube most of all I want to
thank for holding me accountable for my
terrible crimes which I wish I could go
back and
undo I've had a severe it's like it's
like m
mean something I'm curious about is like
I'm actually surprised that she got in
trouble at all because as We Know
YouTube likes to take a super hands-off
approach with it actions that happen not
on the platform
um the doxing happened on Instagram yeah
they had they did she get in trouble on
in like can you dox people on Instagram
like shouldn't that be an issue it
should be but for her account Zuck
doesn't care crazy
but YouTube has a uh policy that they
added is the one they cited where like
the conduct thing or whatever it during
a
really what was it was it was it the
Shane thing or it was some big
controversy where they did something
super [__] up but not on
YouTube what was it was it Alex
Jones
no no what a but the chat might know
anyway once it gets out there yeah they
have this rule about the whatever off
platform Behavior so there it is let me
click his name and see what's popping
over here uh careful with
the with that back
there let's
see oh they're showing old tweets of
Jack it says what is with Twitter they
go Jack's film is trending I click it
and it's showing Jack film tweets from
October
13th how was that
helpful yeah it's pretty bad over there
these days here's another one from
October 13 October
13 October 17 that's three days ago holy
[__] if he's trending show me the new
tweets man October 13 I haven't even
seen a new tweet yet here five hours
this is
from wait did they tag the wrong person
no I think this is a struggles
films I think this person is not the
real Jack it's just making a
joke
okay
okay so there it is that's there's your
new tweet yeah somebody said it was the
Onan guy maybe maybe yeah on yeah it
could have been
onion could have been him
that [__] was crazy and wild thought it
was a bigger one than that
though uh anyway
so there it is and then I had a hard
time the rest of so justice has been
served I guess you might say that some
form of Justice yeah um I hope Jack can
find a way to keep that channel going
just because it's a good thing he's got
there yeah I do wonder if they told him
he's got a the kaios on it the reason I
say that is just because they've told me
this same [__] right and I made three
videos three well you know
sourced professional yeah professional
you know what I mean like they're not
just talking [__] you know there's work
there you're a professional hater yeah
exactly I take my job very
soon all right well that's about it
that's it okay Ethan hold on there is
one thing I wanted to say about Gaza no
I'm
kidding
good got him good good good so
um if we're getting to the end of the
show yeah just uh wanted to give a
reminder that uh we
have uh Pokemon man coming in next week
wait is that Halloween week oh my God is
that Halloween week next week or no it's
not so Halloween is on a Tuesday so no
not next week it's the following Tuesday
which is got it Tuesday might be the the
worst day for Halloween to be on yeah it
happens man Monday will be the Halloween
show so yeah Monday will be our
Halloween episode uh that everybody can
look forward to and uh and we might have
a real spicy guest on leftovers next
week too but um everyone
knows H it's Vivic everyone knows oh
we'll see if he confirms we see I think
I think it's I think it's looking
good okay
damn like I said I got to do a lot of
prep um also the director's card of
infra brand video is up on the
director's got right just the extended
which is basically just the raw footage
INF extra stff kind to spam in the
shot I don't know Vivic it's going to be
interesting Viv VI
Viv like cake I remember
yeah so you have a week to practice that
I got it you got it you got it the
V so that would be interesting I like
when we're getting
more like it's it's pretty cool that
we're getting like you know serious
political MH people talk there's a
there's another guest we're working on
for leftovers that I am thrilled about
but more updates on that as uh as they
come along send Discord
everybody knows that oh yeah that would
be [__] awesome that's have we made
have we made contact not yet but it's
we're working on we'll talk I believe in
it we're yeah I'm I'm I'm manifesting it
I'm manifesting it I'm deep undercover
all right everybody
listen that's the week that's it it's
been a good one it's been a crazy one a
heavy one yeah tears laughter emotions
it's all dumb it's all happening here at
the a stre podcast Nobody Does it Like
Us four 5 days a week to include the
member stream mhm people can't they
can't keep up and yet here I still am
can't get somebody to review my [__]
monetization all good thank you to all
the members thank you to everybody who's
watching I hope you all have a fantastic
weekend and we will be back uh next week
with another great week of shows so
thank you and we'll see you then thanks
for watching
[Music]
what